Ich glaube, wir wären zu spät, wenn wir hier wo
einmal
no god please no no no
ja
so was id liegt monkaS
guckt euch mal an meine id ultraliegte id ja omg id liegt
ja ich hab was getrunken also was passiert heute kann ich euch erzählen ich geb zu der
titel ist nicht ganz ganz klar ich bin nicht so ganz sicher wie weit wir kommen beziehungsweise
was davon wir machen werden chat ihr schreibt wirres zeug das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn
so also was wir heute machen ist folgendes es gibt so ein paar punkte ach ja und die
desktop hintergründe müssen wir eigentlich auch noch machen das machen wir heute nicht
also was wir heute machen ist folgendes wir beschäftigen uns etwas mit google cloud ich
stelle mir das so in zwei drei teilen vor wie wir das machen also nicht alles heute aber mal
gucken so das erste ist wir legen da ein paar sachen übers web interface angucken uns das mal
alles soweit an weil wie gesagt ich habe ja da auch noch nicht so viel so viel alles mögliche
mir angeguckt so also ich meine ich kann projekte anlegen kann vm so anlegen und so was aber z.b.
wie man eine container registry anliegt oder so keine ahnung dann oder mal custom netzwerke
anlegen und so was und dann ich weiß nicht ob das eine gute idee wäre ich gehe davon aus dass
studio code erweiterung nicht so schwierig zu programmieren ist aber ich habe keine gute
idee für eine erweiterung so also wir gucken uns erst mal so ein bisschen google cloud im browser
an ich bin auch schon eingeloggt hier leute ich muss mal kurz die andere musik machen natürlich
durch bei ja komm wir machen ein bisschen wupp wupp an wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp
ich gehe davon aus das gibt es schon mehr zu genüge also ich glaube nur visual studio code
erweiterung die chat gpt für git commits integriert wird es gar nicht schon geben das ist das so
naheliegend das haben schon 50 andere leute gemacht so also zumindest ich bin auch schon eingeloggt wie
ihr seht guckt da hier google cloud am start ich habe ein streamprojekt angelegt das ist auch das
einzige projekt was ich habe ich hatte vorher noch ein anderes dieses das defaultprojekt aber das
habe ich vorhin gelöscht ich hoffe der mittlerweile alle ressourcen freigegeben
weil kubernetes cluster erzeugen dauert ewig über das web interface generell über
das web in google cloud überall dauert das lang ja eindeutig solltest dich bewerben damit
direkt kannst du reinschreiben expertise cloud storage usage vielleicht solltest du noch
schreiben was du was du da drinne hast 300 terabyte auf was hast du irgendwelche camgirl sessions
mitgeschnitten wo aus der irgendwas auf 300 terabyte zu kommen urlaubsfotos ok dann nicht
also das erste was ich mir überlegt habe ist wir gucken uns mal ein bisschen an bei manchen
sagen kann ich euch was zu sagen bei manchen auch nicht so mal schauen bis wir vielleicht auch die
ein oder anderen sachen mal zusammen angucken also folgende folgende punkte will ich will ich mir
angucken und zwar wie man die container registry anlegt wie man das ordentlich mit netzwerken
macht dann legen wir kubernetes cluster an dann legen wir cloud sql datenbank an und danach weil
wir uns angeguckt haben im web interface wie das alles funktioniert das probieren das mal
terraform zu machen terraform google cloud bissl was habe ich schon gemacht auf der arbeit
muss ich tatsächlich gar nicht so viel machen da ist vieles schon fertig die haben jede menge
custom terraform module aber wenn man wenn man ja so eigene sachen machen will die da nicht
vorgesehen sind brauche man das doch und das ziel das ganze ich denke mal das das dauert jetzt
mal bestimmt drei streams und ich glaube das kann man auch ganz gut ganz gut aufsplitten also das
ziel das ganze das ganze ist dass wir im endeffekt dann einen service im google kubernetes laufen
haben einen api server einen frontend server eine cloud sql datenbank und das ganze dann auch in
cluster verschlüsseln das ist ganz witzig weil ich muss auf der arbeit gerade was ähnliches
machen beziehungsweise ich war so blöd habe ich freiwillig dazu gemeldet das das einzurichten und
da dachte ich mir wenn man schon auf der web wenn ich da schon mal was mache in der richtung da
können wir hier auch uns paar sachen davon natürlich jetzt hat nichts mit der firma zu tun wo ich
arbeite aber mein google cloud ist google cloud und ein paar sachen angucken wie das so funktioniert
das heißt heute das heißt heute gucken wir uns mal ein bisschen google cloud an sich an dann
gucken wir an wie man das ganze per terraform provisioniert und dann brauchen wir noch eine
beispielanwendung das weiß ich nicht ob wir das heute machen vielleicht machen wir das auch im
nächsten stream wir brauchen eine beispielanwendung bestehend aus drei teilen eigentlich zwei teile
ja ein javascript frontend das wird was ganz simples das wird eine webseite mit einem button
und wenn man da draufklickt dreht sich ein cac w-build oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung
sondern nicht kompliziert wird das nicht also wir brauchen eine backend anwendung mit irgendeine
api-schnittstelle frontend die wir von einem anderen container dann ausliefern können und
am endeffekt irgendeine postgres cloud datenbank die können wir heute vielleicht schon professionieren
über terraform das müssen wir mal gucken also das müssen wir machen und dann werden wir gucken
wie man das möglichst agil und dynamisch auf ein kubernetes cluster deploit so dass man das
alles ordentlich managen kann ich bin mir nicht sicher wo wir genau heute anfangen wo wir genau
aufhören aber ich gehe davon aus dass das grob ungefähr drei streams firebase nee warum
ich weil ich will das ist ein bisschen bezug zu dem was ich auf der arbeit machen muss und da ist
es nicht firebase weil das hatte ist immer ein vorteil wenn wenn das was ich da gelernt habe wenn
ich das hier mal so ein bisschen in streams verarbeiten kann umgedreht was ich hier lerne
dass ich das auf der arbeit benutzen kann das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch das heißt ich werde
jetzt erstmal hauptsächlich sachen benutzen von den ich weiß dass ich die da auch benutzen kann
firebase ist nichts nichts davon keines keines davon ja das läuft im endeffekt raus dass wir
dann wir wahrscheinlich machen wir eine dotnet core api-server anwendung irgend so eine billige
weltweb anwendung mit einem button drinne zum zum bild rotieren und dann gibt es einen nginx
server der das frontend ausliefert cloud postgres cloud sql datenbank das wir uns mal anschauen wie
wir das machen ja weil ich habe mich gestern auf der arbeit freiwillig dazu gemeldet weil
es ist wirklich ein bisschen anstrengend gerade ich kann irgendwie nichts technisch machen meine
accounts funktionieren teilweise nicht und du musst erst mal durch fünf muss erst mal fünf
hürden umschiffen bis zu irgendwas machen kannst das heißt gestern habe ich erfahren da gibt es
ein neues projekt und die machen das oder zumindest ein teil eines neuen projekts gibt
und die ne ist immer noch ist immer noch nicht alles freigeschaltet ein teil eines neuen projekts
gibt und die wollen jetzt erst mal so ein proof of concept in der cloud aufbauen für zum testen von
ihren sachen habe ich gleich gesagt jungs das mache ich weil da muss man keine internen abläufe
mit 500 teams und 500 berechtigung sonst was machen dann logste nicht einfach ein und legst
das erst mal so an wie es dir danach ist das mache ich keine frage da kann ich wenigstens
was sinnvolles machen weil es wirklich schlimm ist jetzt die zweite woche rum und ich habe
nichts großartig technik bisher gemacht ich kann auch nicht mal technik großartig machen also sehr
sehr weird champ alles noch ja deswegen das mache ich das und da habe ich vorgeschlagen wir können
das ja so machen also die sind noch ganz das ist noch ganz frisch die haben die haben aktuell
läuft die anwendung bei denen noch rein rein lokal in dockercontainern und wir haben halt gesagt
ja gut wir hauen das in kubernetes cluster rein da meinten die halt es gibt noch überhaupt kein
überhaupt noch kein image und sonst was aber sie können mir docker files liefern jetzt kein
problem wie ich baue die images selbst und vielleicht bauen wir für die zukunft auch
in den helm chart raus aber schickt schickt einfach schickt einfach euer docker und jetzt wollen sie
mir binaries schicken und dockerfile ich soll die images selbst machen mache ich überhaupt kein
problem das heißt da gucken wir uns heute auch mal an wie man eine container registry in der
google cloud anlegt und am besten natürlich das alles über terraform müssen wir mal gucken wie
gesagt ich weiß noch nicht genau wo wir anfangen wo wir aufhören nee der hat noch nicht die
probleme weil der hat noch gar nicht angefangen der fängt am montag an übermorgen der fängt
hier an und ich gehe davon aus der hatte gleich probleme ich habe sogar zwei wochen
vorsprung wahrscheinlich kann ich ihm dann die ein oder anderen sache zeigen die er nicht
selbst raus rausfinden muss wir machen mal kurz ein update weil wir sind ja nach wie vor unter
achtsch by the way unterwegs für die coolen leute hier arch muss sein archlinux masterrace
gibt es nichts besseres alles noobs wenn ich arch benutzt gentoo lasse ich mir vielleicht auch
noch gefallen ich sollte das pro stream öfters öfters erwähnen auf der anderen seite verschenke
ich dann die chance dass die leute fragen und ich will eine halbe stunde über mein archlinux
reden kann also wahrscheinlich wäre es besser ich sage gar nichts dazu so erst mal erst einmal
kurz ein bisschen package updates machen immer und das brauchen wir nicht mehr ich glaube die
eikens verwende ich gar nicht egal ich lasse trotzdem update vor ich jetzt sachen lösche
alles mal update soll ich euch mal das beste kommen zeigen was ich auf youtube in letzter
zeit bekommen habe youtube
sag uns lieber mal deine meinung zu c++ ja das haben wir auch so selten schon gemacht
ja also das sind so die sachen die so für die nächsten ich weiß nicht ob das die nächsten
zwei zwei drei streams in folge sein wird sondern aber es wird auf jeden fall in über
zwei drei streams gehen was wir google cloud technisch jetzt bauen das wird ein komplettes
setup ja also das gibt dann container registry irgendeine vm die man als als also mit privates
privates netzwerk in der cloud in der vm wo man drüber reinkommt zum administrieren in privaten
kubernetes cluster container registry ingress also dass man von außen auf die anwendung zugreifen
kann vielleicht irgendwie in flux argo cd oder sonst was zum automatisch deployen für neue
sachen das muss man sagen wir können nicht allzu große nee ist noch nicht fertig wir haben noch
gar nicht angefangen 15 minuten das wollte ich jetzt sagen wir können nicht ganz so große
sprünge hier in der cloud machen weil das ist ein demo account und ich habe irgendwo wo sieht
man das leute warum steht denn das auf deutsch ich habe gerade billing gesucht warum steht das auf
deutsch monka es das muss weg oder ich weiß überhaupt nicht wie der wieder kämpel hier
auf eine mal einstellungen oder nein fake email liegt omg sprache und region ja das müssen wir
umstellen also ihr seht schon das ist ein account den habe ich explizit angelegt hier zum stream
zum test da läuft sonst nix drinne ok ich habe billing da ist es doch das habe ich gesucht
genau und ich habe noch budget 284 euro von 284 euro habe ich noch übrig wir können aber
trotzdem keine allzu großen sprünge machen weil ich zeige euch mal quotas
obai das ist jetzt nur für das projekt ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob man das da schon
sieht solange ich kupane das noch nicht eingeschaltet habe ja also was man hier zum
Beispiel sieht ist dass man ja man hat man hat verschiedene quotas zum beispiel hat man auch
ein quota für vm storage total storage und ihr seht ich habe ein limit von 250 g also sprich
ich wir können jetzt kein irgendwie acht acht not kubernetes cluster dahin bauen wir können
wahrscheinlich zum testen so ein wir machen zwei zwei not klasse reicht reicht ja vollkommen aus
also man kann da keine so große sprünge machen die limits sind auch hardcoded also ich kann die
nicht kann die nicht vergrößern weil der account ist wie gesagt ist ein demo account die wollen
natürlich nicht dass irgendjemand übernacht 10.000 euro da in den demo account rein haut bevor
sie es überhaupt checken und sonst was also wir sind ein bisschen wir sind ein bisschen limitiert
also man sieht hier kommt mal in limit wir wir sind europe west europe west 3 ist glaube
ich frankfurt können wir gleich mal gucken ich glaube europe west 3 ist frankfurt europe west
3 frankfurt ja
genau also wir haben wir haben 250 gigabyte ssd limit da können wir jetzt nicht so viel machen
das eine sache und dann müssen wir uns mal angucken wie das alles funktioniert wir können
schon mal ein projekt anlegen ja mach mal update ja wenn du was spezifisches wissen willst kannst
du mich fragen ansonsten denke ich aber ist das eher in richtung das ist wie wenn der
lehrer dir in der schule 45 minuten was erzählte du hast nichts verstanden am ende fragte ein
habt ihr noch fragen oder so max hast du noch fragen ja ja was dann ja alles ich weiß nicht
habe nichts verstanden so ungefähr wird das wahrscheinlich sein wie gesagt der fängt erst
an so ungefähr stelle ich mir das stelle ich mir das vor wenn man gar keine ahnung davon hat
aber du kannst natürlich kannst natürlich zeug fragen wenn du was wissen willst
so sieht es aus wir werden auf eine sache zurückgreifen heute zum testen und zwar auf unsere
app die wir das letzte mal gebaut haben auf die hier cute cute app auf die hier werden wir
zurückgreifen die macht nichts anderes wie hallo chat auf der webseite ausgeben das war es also
hält sich hält sich sehr in grenzen aber das eine praktische praktische demo aber wobei ich gar
nicht weiß ob wir das brauchen hat google cloud eigentlich mittlerweile ein dark dark sieben ja
gegeben preference ja moment moment cloud shell
nee anscheinend nicht da war mein dark reader an weil das plant mich zu sehr
ist da auch blockchain und ai auf der webseite kannst in der gut du kannst vms laufen lassen
kannst drin alles laufen lassen was du willst wenn du genug speicherplatz hast und blockchain
sachen laufen zu können weil das ist ja recht speicherintensiv so ach ja ich wollte euch ja
das beste kommen zeigen was ich in letzter zeit so auf youtube gekriegt haben wo ich nicht wo ich
bin ich sicher bin ob der trolls oder ob das ob er das ernst meint aber müsst ihr euch mal
müsst ihr euch mal durchlesen und zwar hier also er bezieht sich auf folgendes ich sage das ganz
am anfang vom video heute rechnet man merkt halt einfach wenn man zehn jahre und mehr ich meine ich
war ja zwölf jahre und relativ lang beim gleichen laden jetzt gewesen man gewöhnt sich da gleich
um ein zehnjähriges eine sache habe ich geschafft mit dem wechsel ich habe mich erfolgreich um ein
zehnjähriges jubiläumsessen mit dem oberit chef gedrückt das hat er gehört in dem video und das
gefällt ihm irgendwie nicht dass ich keinen bock hat mit dem oberit chef essen zu gehen
chat frage an euch mal angenommen ihr arbeitet in der it viele von euch machen das ja auch und
ihr würdet zum zehnjährigen jubiläum anstatt irgendwie eine bonuszahlung oder irgendwas
sinnvolles zu bekommen ein treffen mit allen anderen zehnjährigen jubilanten und dem oberit
chef bekommen würdet ihr hingehen ja oder nein immer dort ja die bezahlen die bezahlen
ja ja das essen bezahlen die essen bezahlen die was gibt es zu essen ich weiß ich nicht was zu
essen also ich hatte da per se persönlich ich hatte da persönlich überhaupt kein bock drauf
also ok als chat chat ich glaube die meist im chat hier würden sagen wenn überhaupt dann wenn
es essen bezahlt wird ja klar aber also ich habe da kein bock drauf das hat mehrere gründe warum
ich da kein bock drauf habe der erste offensichtlichste grund ist ich habe
überhaupt keinerlei schnittmenge mit unserem oberit chef gehabt und ich habe den kerl zweimal
zweimal gesehen und du kannst davon da kannst davon ausgehen dass wenn du dort sitzt und mit
dem reden muss so ein bisschen smalltalk mit muss halt auf jedes wort achten was du sagst
und auch wenn ich mit den leuten keine schnittmenge dazu kommt dass die letzten jahre schon nicht
sonderlich toll gelaufen sind die firma mir extrem auf den sack gegangen ist so von wegen wir halten
uns nicht an absprachen wir haben keinen bock mehr auf home office und auch wenn es probleme gab haben
die sich nie irgendwie mal dazu herab gelassen tatsächlich mal ein bisschen auf die leute zuzugehen
und zu sagen ja ok was ist denn jetzt eigentlich genau das problem wie können wir das jetzt hand
haben auf der einen seite wollte man immer wie gesagt im alten unternehmen wo ich war wollte man
immer dass die leute das machen was die firma will aber die firma wollte quasi nie das machen was
man persönlich jetzt vielleicht mal gebraucht hätte zum beispiel hatte ich einen kollege bei
mir im team der musste einmal seinen urlaub absagen muss ich euch mal vorstellen den urlaub
glaube ich in italien gebucht der fährt gerne motorrad und hat irgendwie hotels gebucht dass
er da rumfahrt und hat die firma gesagt hier wir haben jetzt ganz viele probleme bei uns du kannst
nicht in urlaub fahren und da hat er hat er tatsächlich ist er den entgegengekommen und
hat gesagt ja ok da fahre ich irgendwie eine woche später so und dann am ende hat sich raus
gestellt das eine hotel hat er irgendwie irgendwie so gebucht dass er nicht mal zurücktreten konnte
und am ende hat er irgendwie 300 400 euro oder so verloren einfach weil er eine woche länger in
der firma geblieben ist also er ist der firma entgegengekommen und ein jahr später und jetzt
kommt der hammer jetzt kommt es kommt wirklich der hammer ein jahr später hat er gesagt ok die firma
hat sich jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr dazu geäußert wie das mit dem urlaub ist und wie das wie das
werden soll und das letzte mal muss ich schon absagen ich plane jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
später falls den dieses jahr wieder einfällt irgendwelche sonder sachen machen zu müssen und
daraufhin und jetzt haltet euch mal fest daraufhin haben die ihm eine abmahnung geschickt dass er
seinen urlaub nicht rechtzeitig eine abmahnung das wird sich mal vorstellen die haben eine abmahnung
geschickt dass er seinen urlaub nicht rechtzeitig eingereicht hätte und da hat er auch gesagt ich glaube ihr habt
ja nicht mehr alle und der ist jetzt auch demnächst ich kenne den letzten ich kenne den letzten stand
nicht aber so wie es scheint ist er wahrscheinlich auch demnächst weg und das sind so dinge wo ich
mir denke kannst du nicht auf der einen seite immer was haben wollen auf der anderen seite
nichts machen also ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz merkwürdig und solche dinger sind da öfters gelaufen wo man
sich auch nie irgendwie mal dazu bequemt hat mal bei den leuten zu fragen was ist jetzt eigentlich
das problem wie können wir das handhaben dass es für beide seiten passt und dann so ein gestelltes
zehnjähriges essen wo so belangloses zeug gelabert wird was soll ich da machen zumindest ich deswegen
muss ich sagen ich kann ich kann das immer nicht ganz nachvollziehen also er schreibt hier ich glaube
ja das ist ich glaube ja dass das troll kommend ist leute wir lesen uns das jetzt mal durch und ihr
könnt mir danach sagen ob ihr meinen dass das ein troll kommend ist oder nicht es geht noch ein
bisschen weiter also er schreibt sehr schade dass du das jubiläumsessen nicht wahrgenommen hast was
ist der bestimmt chainloss fünfte account oder so hat er mittlerweile schon einige weil er überall
gebannt ist was ist der grund dafür dass du dich so stark abgrenzt die erste frage die ich mir stelle
was verpflichtet mich eigentlich dazu oder was sollte mich irgendwie dazu bringen in meiner freizeit
oder was könnte es sein was mich dazu bringt mich darauf zu freuen in meiner freizeit zwei drei
stunden mich mit kollegen von der bzw das kollegen mit den leuten da habe ich eigentlich gar nichts
zu tun mit direkten kollegen hatte ich da wahrscheinlich gar kein problem mit mit
irgendwelchen random leuten von der arbeit die ich nicht kenne und wo ich bei jedem zweiten
wort überlegen muss ob ich jetzt auch sagen darf warum sollte ich mit den essen gehen das ist die
grundsätzliche frage das ist ja und das habe ich ihm auch geschrieben das ist ja weder meine
familie noch sind das meine freunde oder sonst was in der richtung gerade im hinblick das in was
in den letzten paar jahren gelaufen ist also mache ich lieber was anderes so und jetzt und jetzt hat
er noch mal ausgeholt jetzt hat er noch mal ausgeholt so gibst du dem arbeit deswegen glaube ich doch
dass das ich glaube doch dass das getrollt ist das ist einfach zu zu lost ja kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das ist real ist so gibst du dem arbeitgeber doch die möglichkeit dich besser
kennenzulernen alle hatte zehn jahre zeit mich kennenzulernen vielleicht ist es der big boss
im selbe das glaube ich glaube ich eher nicht einen rahmen in dem man sich offen austauschen kann davon
hat übrigens nie jemand gesprochen dass man sich da offen austauschen kann über das berufliche
hinaus ja da habe ich keinen bock drauf mit den leuten über das berufliche hinaus zu reden wer bist
du was machst du gerne wie kann man dich fördern das kann ich mit meinem chef besprechen das muss
ich mit dem ober artie chef machen außerdem gibt es da genug möglichkeiten die alle nicht
eingehalten wurden was kann man für dich tun damit du dich wohl fühlst ja zum beispiel sich in
absprachen halten wie du beschreibst dass du froh warst an dem gespräch nicht teilnehmen zu
wollen war wenig wertschätzend von das ist korrekt dass es war das war tatsächlich wenig
wertschätzend was aber zum größten teil daran liegt dass sich die firma die letzten jahre über
auch äußerst nicht wertschätzend einem gegenüber verhalten hat im endeffekt meinte man ist nur gut
mit dir ist er wirklich so lost ist er wirklich so los ich weiß nicht also man sollte doch auch
gerade wie ich das erzählt habe in dem video kommt auch auch später dass ich es noch nicht
mal geschafft haben mir bis zum bis zum austrittszeitpunkt alle dokumenten auszustellen
und so was ist das wertschätzend ist das ist es wertschätzend dass ich ich ob ich musste ich
musste als ich in der neuen firma angefangen habe nach einer woche musste ich noch mal bei
der alten arbeit anrufen und sagen die personalabteilung ist zu langsam die
hatten mir immer noch nicht alles geschickt ist das wertschätzend dass man so lahm ist
und dann hieß es jetzt halt jetzt haltet euch mal fest dass muss ich muss ich auch noch an
der stelle erzählen ich war eine woche jetzt schon beim neuen arbeit geht also jetzt das
das jetzt nächste woche ist die dritte woche ich bin jetzt ja schon ein bisschen da nach einer
woche ich glaube erste woche freitag oder so war das bin man ich bin man nicht ganz sicher oder
wann war ostern
letztes wochenende
genau so und da habe ich da im freitag am donnerstag war das dann am donner nee
doch am donnerstag muss es gewesen sein so also es war ja abgemacht dass ich vom alten arbeit
geben eine bescheinigung bekomme wie viel urlaubstage ich schon genommen habe damit die
beim neuen gut geschrieben werden können das geht also wer das nicht weiß das kann man machen wenn
beide seiten zustimmen also mal angenommen er wechselt innerhalb des jahres am ende des
jahres stellt sich die frage ja gar nicht aber mal angenommen er wechselt innerhalb des jahres
wie ich zum beispiel am 1. april dann müsste ihr anteilmäßig habt ihr ja anteilmäßig urlaub
am alten arbeitgeber und ihr habt anteilmäßig dann den restlichen urlaub am neuen arbeitgeber
jetzt könnte es natürlich so sein dass die im ersten halbjahr der urlaub dass ich da eigentlich
gar kein urlaub nehmen wollte ist bei mir so ich habe überhaupt keine gar keine verwendung dafür
gehabt jetzt irgendwie sechs tage urlaub zu machen ich hätte sechs tage urlaub nehmen müssen dass
das dass das quasi beklechen war was ich beim alten arbeitgeber habe deswegen habe ich mal
geguckt es gibt die möglichkeit dass wenn beide seiten zustimmen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es
da gesetzlich irgendwie eine verpflichtung zugibt aber zumindest wenn beide seiten zustimmen dann
kann man den urlaubsanspruch quasi transferieren vom alten arbeitgeber zum neuen arbeitgeber dazu
muss folgendes passieren der neue arbeitgeber muss sagen ja er macht das und der alte arbeitgeber
muss auch sagen ja sie machen mit und er muss dir eine bescheinigung ausstellen wie viele
urlaubstage du schon genommen hast ist ja irgendwie logisch sonst könntest du quasi beim neuen sagen
ich habe noch keine genommen und beim alten dir die ausbezahlen lassen und solche geschichten
das wäre irgendwie wer beschiss also habe ich mir den folgendes ausgemacht hier leute ich war
extra noch mal bei der personal abteilung oben ja habe ich mir den ausgemacht hier leute also das
ist heute mein letzter tag das ist auch da wo ich mein mein zeugnis abgeholt hat mein letzter tag
könnt ihr mir jetzt diese diese bescheinigung schicken dass es bis nächste woche da ist haben
gesagt ja kein problem erster tag neue arbeitgeber selbstverständlich war die bescheinigung vom
alten noch nicht da also was habe ich gemacht nach ich habe dann montag gewartet dienstag
war mittwoch dann habe ich mich nachmittags bei meinem alten chef gemeldet von alten aber hier
guck mal die personal abteilung hat mir hat mir zugesagt es ist bis montag da und es ist
irgendwie mittwoch nachmittag das ist immer noch nicht da was ist denn jetzt was wie sieht
es denn aus das kann es doch nicht sein dankeschön für den sub und dann meinte er ja er fragt noch
mal nach und dann hat er gesagt ja also die personal abteilung hat gesagt sie hätten das
am montag losgeschickt weil offiziell bin ich ja erst am montag weg gewesen okay dann müsste
es ja gleich kommen leute es kam die bescheinigung kam mittlerweile die bescheinigung kam glaube ich
diese woche diese woche dienstag oder sowas und wisst ihr was drauf stand da ist ja immer so
einen so einen stempel von der post so einen so einen wann das wann das eingegangen ist es stand
drauf die haben es losgeschickt am warte mal ich sage jetzt durchblick hier die haben es
losgeschickt am 5.4. das heißt die haben das dann losgeschickt nachdem ich noch mal nachgefragt
habe also sprich die haben das überhaupt nicht gemacht wie besprochen die haben es überhaupt
nicht gemacht wie besprochen die haben erst nachdem ich gefragt haben das vergessen erst
nachdem ich gefragt habe haben sie noch mal das dann losgeschickt das ist auch sehr wertschätzend
oder findet ihr nicht auch was auch immer die müssen gar nichts machen miteinander der neue
kann die einfach übernehmen ich meine denn der neue hat ja eigentlich gar kein interesse
da dran wenn man zwar so nimmt das zu machen weil er müsste er bekommt mich dann dafür quasi
vier tage weniger muss mich die zeit bezahlen der alte freut sich der alte freut sich weil
ich noch vier tage länger für ihn arbeite aber ich glaube so kleinlich sind die dann nicht in der
neue hat er gesagt dass er es macht dankeschön kst für den sub na mobile games kannst du da
ein spiel das ist so eine veranstaltung mit entertainment da sitzt du dann da und da gibt
sein in den programm und irgendwelche leute dansen darum oder so und nebenbei gibt es was zu essen
muss smalltalk mit dem oberit chef halten das ja ganz bestimmt ganz bestimmt ne da hatte ich
wirklich überhaupt kein bock drauf dafür bin ich in der management hier archie eben noch nicht
hoch genug glaube ich und jetzt jetzt deswegen mal übrigens das ist der grund warum ich denke
dass das ein troll comment ist kein wunder dass du nicht mehr nicht mehr dort arbeitest wenn du
einen wichtigen teil der unternehmenskultur ablehnst ein arbeitgeber vor 50 jahren sehr gut zu dir
passen also entweder ist das einfach nur hyperlost das kommen wenn das ernst mein oder es es ist recht
gutgeschriebene troll comments ich glaube zweiter ich glaube nicht dass das wirklich ernst mein
genau ja das ist doch kein ding da würde ich auch tatsächlich mit mit denen hat man ja auch
direkte schnittmenge da völlig keine keine schmerzen mit aus dem mittagessen ja mittagessen ist kein
problem das andere wäre irgendwie so einen vier stunden abendprogramm habe ich noch am
freitag am ist noch habe ich gar kein bock drauf gehabt ja schön dass ihr alle da seid ich habe
gesehen der das ist aber habe ich nicht habe ich die im dark theme eingeschaltet doch habe ich ja
schön dass ihr alle da seid ich sehe das stream ist jetzt angelaufen also ich erzähle noch mal ganz
schnell was wir heute machen wobei ich bin selbst nicht ganz sicher bin wo wir anfangen und wo wir
aufhören die beschäftigung ist heute ein bisschen mit google cloud als erstes legen wir
mal ein paar sachen von hand an dann gucken wir über das ganze per terraform professionieren können
dann gucken wir wie man den kubanitas cluster anlegt wobei ich sicher bin ob wir das heute
machen über terraform weil das dauert immer ewig generell kubanitas engine hier provisioning dauert
ewig da kannst du teilweise 20 minuten zugucken wie der den cluster anlegt dann basteln wir eine
beispielanwendung die pläne cloud sql datenbank und lassen das darauf laufen mit verschlüsselung
unter den containern mit einem eingang von außen das werden wir heute nicht alles hinbekommen es
wird so über 23 ich vermute mal eher drei streams gehen heute gucken wir uns so die grundlagen an
beziehungsweise das was man wir klicken ein bisschen das von hand zusammen was wir dann am
endeffekt automatisch professionieren wollen und im dritten stream kümmern wir uns dann um den
kubanitas cluster so denke ich mal dass wir das machen das heißt wenn ihr dabei sein wollt jetzt
die nächsten 23 streams ein bisschen bock auf google google cloud 5 hätte habt dann ist es
natürlich eine optimale gelegenheit zu folgen und zu subscriben aus dem freue ich mich drüber
warum nicht magenta cloud ja da bin ich ganz scharf drauf auf magenta cloud ich finde mein
ich finde mein telekom imot nicht da ist es also magenta cloud ist glaube ich open stack oder
wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe und ich kenne niemand der magenta cloud benutzt im business
umfeld kennt ihr jemand kennt ihr irgendjemand in der firma die magenta cloud benutzt außer
die telekom selbst und bei ob sie telekom selbst benutzt ist ja auch schon fraglich
ok geht laut habe ich das installiert nein habe ich nicht erst mal erst mal das erste was man
braucht um irgendwas mit alter laut das erste was man braucht ist man braucht das google cloud
cli man braucht sich unbedingt aber es ist sehr von vorteil die google cloud kommt das google
cloud command line interface sich zu installieren das kann man entweder machen wenn man art
stillungs verwendet hier über dieses art user repo oder man kann es auch das ist ziemlich
einfach zu installieren oder man kann es auch das mache ich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch so weil
ich habe in meiner shell schon die config drinne home max downloads g cloud siehste dann machen
wir das mal hier linux google clouds cli 64 bit copy link we get man kann das auch selbst
also man muss es nur einmalig einmalig installieren so und jetzt sollte ich eigentlich habe ich nicht
ok ich bin blöd ich hätte unterordner machen sollen lull lull w mk dir g cloud move google
cloud sdk warum auch immer ich den unterordner gemacht habe keine ahnung da haben wir es doch
ok das ist das erste was man machen muss sonst kannst du nämlich vergessen was mit google cloud
zu machen du kannst zwar auch alles im webinterface klicken aber spätestens bei so sachen wie
weiterleiten auf nur vm und solche geschichten funktioniert nicht übers webinterface alleine
das muss man also man braucht das man braucht das command line command line interface das wenn
irgendwas vor hat mit google cloud zu machen dann würde ich euch empfehlen direkt google
cloud zu installieren irgendwelchen gründen ok jetzt geht's so und dann muss man machen g
cloud wir haben übrigens auch direkt out of the box wie ihr seht autocomplete components update
kann man dann mal hinterher schießen das hat nämlich in eigenen updater drinne do you want
to opt in in reporting no so ich habe sie auch gerade runtergeladen gerade installiert also
dementsprechend ist es aktuell geben wir mal unsere repos mk dir ja legen wir uns mal ein repo an für
unsere was auch immer wir für dateien brauchen wir sagen jetzt können wir anfangen das erste ist
man muss sich anmelden bei google cloud mit dem cli ich glaube das ginge einfach so ne na super
ne wie ging das application default kann man sich mal aus dem kopf nicht merken alter ok
das macht man einmal und dann und dann nicht wieder wir können uns wir können auch gleich
schon mal das tutorial aufmachen wie man mit terraform google kubernetes cluster provisioned
das müssen wir nicht mehr machen das habe ich schon gemacht ach das habe ich gebraucht genau
das hat übrigens nichts mit terraform zu tun auch wenn es vielleicht so aussieht jetzt auf
der seite das ist standard standard login bei google cloud mit dem cli dann geht der
falsche browser auf was natürlich auch sehr sehr nice ist dann schnappen wir uns mal das
long uns hier ein ja lau liegt das ist nicht schlimm dass das liegt ist das einzige was
ihr machen könntet mit dem link eventuell und da bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher
ihr könntet mich für euer google cloud projekt authentifizieren ich glaube das wollt ihr nicht
ok ich weiß nicht was er mir sagen will aber es hat funktioniert jetzt kann ich jetzt kann
ich das google cloud cli verwenden und das das brauchen wir auch gleich also ziel heute
ist folgendes wir machen mal machen aber hier notiz notiz auf das brauchen wir eh nicht können
das jetzt mal neues also wir brauchen eine container registry da wollen wir image rein
pushen also müssen wir auch gucken wie das mit mit credentials und so was funktioniert in der
hoffnung ich liege meine credentials zu meiner container registry nicht im stream weil da muss
ich sie wieder löschen das wäre alles nicht so vorteilhaft dann gucken wir uns wie man
netzwerke anlegen kann dann legen wir eine vm anlegen und tunneln da drauf per ssh schauen
wie man das gescheit macht also weiß ich wie man das macht das ist eines der sachen wo ich
weiß wie es funktioniert dann legen wir einen zwei notes google google kubernetes an
klassen an dann legen wir eine cloud sql datenbank an das wird eine postgres
wie sprecht ihr eigentlich postgres aus leute es gibt ja da so ein bisschen auch
ein so zwei lager es gibt leute die sprechen ist postgres aus weil das projekt heißt ja
postgres ql beziehungsweise heißt eigentlich je nachdem wie man es ausspricht also manche
leute manche leute sprechen das projekt so aus postgres ql manche sprechen ist postgres ql aus
und wenn sie es dann abkürzen sagen manche leute post gre oder postgres
also wie würdet ihr postgres ql abkürzen post gre oder postgres postgres oder post gre ich bin
mir gar nicht sicher ob die nicht eine offiziellen guide dafür haben wie man das auch ich spreche
es auch immer postgres aus pg sql ja das ist natürlich das natürlich da alter chain law timeout
pronunciation na wie man postgres ausspricht ist klar die frage ist ob man es abkürzt mit post gre
oder postgres also ich persönlich bin ja team postgres wobei ich pg sql auch nicht schlecht
finde da hast du überhaupt keine probleme mehr aber auf der arbeit habe ich welche die stehen
unglaublich auf post gre ich finde das immer ein bisschen cringe aber man kann ja jeder aussprechen
wie er will so und wenn wir das gemacht haben dann gucken wir wie man das alles mit terraform
provisioniert als ich das richtig geschrieben habe so schauen wir mal schauen wir mal wie
weit wir heute kommen also das erste ist wir probieren das im webinterface aus
webinterface und danach kommen wir das mit terraform
der terraform provider ist trash warum
also außer dass alles ewig dauert aber das ist ja bei google cloud normal ist eigentlich bei
allen cloud anbieter ich habe den eindruck dass tatsächlich es schon noch am schnellsten ist
beim anlegen von ressourcen sonst was ja schauen wir mal nichtdestotrotz probiere ich das mal aus
mit dem provider so das gucken wir uns an dann also wahrscheinlich ist das hier ein guter punkt für
stream stopp heute dann als nächstes müssen wir eine beispielanwendung machen also ein
ein frontend javascript ding das ist aber nichts großartiges ja das wird ein button zum klicken
also das ist was ganz kleines da brauchen eine frontend js anwendung wir brauchen eine backend
also auch zwei zeilen zwei zeilen die einfach irgendwie was ausliefert nix großartiges
zwei stunden krasser scheiß also ich das längste worauf ich mal gewartet habe das war auch terraform
bei google google google company das anlegen war glaube ich 35 minuten für den e-note cluster 35
minuten ich weiß nicht was der ob das an terraform lag oder das google einfach langsam war über
35 minuten so und also ich hatte zumindest bei gut bei aks die leitung das ist schneller erstellt
als bei google so und das muss dann connecten zu einer cloud sql postgres so das war vielleicht
an dem übernächsten stream und dann kümmern wir uns das ist dann der dritte schritt dann kümmern
wir uns um das kubanete setup also mit get ops und wir machen dann tatsächlich mal was mit einem
service mesh dass nämlich die inter anwendungs kommunikation auch noch verschlüsselt wird
ingress cloud lb und dann könnte darauf zugreifen da muss ich auch gucken wie man eine domain auf
gcp bekommt da weiß ich gar nicht wahrscheinlich in der kappa lul.com oder sowas als domain auf geht
habe ich noch gar nicht gemacht welches mesh wahrscheinlich linker die weil das mega simpel
zum aufsetzen ist und für einfache sachen total ausreicht und mtls mega easy ist einfach
eine annotation suchen eine annotation eintragen gut ist konsul habe ich noch nicht verwendet
konsul kann ich gar nicht sagen also das war jetzt gut gucken wir uns das mal an wir legen
schon mal ein leeres terraform projekt an was heißt was heißt leeres terraform
weder ein volles noch ein leeres terraform projekt wir legen einfach mal ein terraform
projekt an und zwar wir kopieren uns mal schnell das da muss ich das nicht selbst schreiben wir
kopieren uns mal schnell die haben noch hier so ein beispielprojekt oder zum netzwerk anlegen
sowas wir nehmen wir nehmen nicht das hier von denen komplett sondern plus dieses plus
dieses eine feil ja ja wir trusten dem autor das kopieren wir rein variable project all die
ja gut ergibt ergibt wahrscheinlich sogar sind dann brauchen wir eine erweiterung für
visual studio code das für ordentlich terraform zeich oh alter warum hatten das ding so schlechte
schlechte bewertung die scheint richtig zu sagen die terraform extension warum sagt die so
warum ist sie so schlecht
nice
ok die extension ist wohl mega beschissen aber wir stellen jetzt trotzdem
mal gucken ob man damit dann wirklich so viel probleme bekommt ich habe einen guten pc das
stimmt ich habe vor allem eine gute vm meine vm hat acht cpu kerne und 24 gigabyte ram das
das sollte denke ich das sollte denke ich erst mal reichen wie macht man in terraform terraform
punkt war es nie wie ging das noch mal auf v war es oder sowas in der richtung
haben sie doch tf war es haben sie auch drin stehen f war es so und ich war jetzt so mal
dass das das project set ab wir klicken erst mal wir klicken erst mal von hand uns gleich durch
durch web interface nur eine sache wollte ich euch jetzt gleich schon mal zeigen wo man darauf achten
muss sollte man sollte man google cloud mit terraform machen beziehungsweise sollte man
erst mit einem demo account und terraform machen nämlich war ich hier war ich hier das
beispiel ja nämlich nicht nicht so wie die das hier wie die das hier machen also das kann man an
der stelle kann man schon machen aber da muss noch ein bisschen mehr hin also projekt ID kriegt
wir wollen europ west 3 wollen wir haben aber was wir auch noch haben wollen ist wir wollen
location weil standardmäßig ist es so dass wenn du bei einem zum beispiel kuban das cluster den
über terraform erstellt in google cloud oder auch wenn es mal web interface erstellt glaube
ich zumindest dass er das irgendwie regionweit noch im hintergrund irgendwie discs repliziert
und sonst was und dann kommt man mit dem 300 gigabyte oder 250 gigabyte storage limit des
demo accounts nicht aus das heißt man muss nicht sagen dass man den cluster in der region aufmacht
sondern man muss sagen dass man den können es auch zone nennen ja dass man den so dass man den
cluster in der zone aufmacht eine zone und eine region ist folgender unterschied also europe 3
ist in dem fall wie nennen die das wie nennen das bei google es ist frankfurt aber das gibt es
auch noch mit unterschiedlichen quasi unterteilung das gibt es quasi als abc so und wenn man das
ganze jetzt regionweit aufbauen lässt dann repliziert er das ja so ein bisschen dann
würde das quasi replizieren in alle anderen zonen unterhalb von dieser region was cool ist
wenn man das braucht was totaler platzverschwendung ist wenn man das nicht braucht deswegen würde ich
noch eine zone anlegen wenn wir das hier auch mal zone und das wollen wir nicht weil wir haben
250 gigabyte platz so das hier ist ok region alles gut das können wir auch so lassen das ist
alles das alles in ordnung und wir können jetzt schon mal das terraform wie habe ich nicht
installiert tatsächlich hast du schon mal trp 10 benutzt nee ich weiß aber was das ist das ist
diese geschichte die irgendwie kraft kl konkurrenz machen soll terraform in it
alles klar terraform apply ich apply jetzt nicht ich guck bloß ob es theoretisch funktionieren
würde das würden würde würden sie anlegen ok alles gut nice wobei wir können das wir können
das auch gleich anlegen lassen wir haben jetzt ja noch nix gemacht bisher als wenn man hier
reinguckt compute engine nicht compute engine vpc networks kann man sich angucken was es für
was es für netzwerke in der google cloud gibt da gibt es nur das default netzwerk so in seiner
standard du hast die zone variabler erstellt aber benutzt du nirgends das ist richtig ich benutze
die noch nirgends ich werde die dann beim cluster erstellen oder beim vm erstellen verwenden aber
aktuell brauche ich das nicht das netzwerk muss man glaube ich so weit ich weiß sogar in der
region erstellen und es gibt keine es gibt keine location angabe fürs netzwerk muss man machen das
braucht man dann erst bei späteren ressourcen aktuell legen wir plus netzwerke an da ist es
nicht da ist es nicht weiter wild genau so als es also noch nix noch nix großartig angelegt das
sieht standardmäßig so aus wenn man ein neues projekt erstellt in der google cloud das sind
die default ip ranges und wir legen jetzt ein eigenes netzwerk an für unsere spiele rein also
wie gesagt ziel für heute ist wir wollen am ende eine container registry haben mit images wo man
images reinpushen kann netzwerke eine vm mal gucken wie man uns damit vms tunneln können da
habe ich auch noch nicht so die große erfahrung ich weiß wie es geht aber noch nicht ausbilden
kommen ins klasse da klicken wir mal was webinterface zusammen ich glaube bis wir das
über terraform konfiguriert haben sprengt den rahmen unterlegen wir über terraform noch eine
cloud sql datenbank an die war die zweite woche beim job besser als die erste woche aber viel
technik konnte ich immer noch nicht machen deswegen habe ich jetzt freiwillig mich dazu
gemeldet was neues aufzubauen unter anderem auch auf google cloud wo man nicht so viel internes
knowledge über die ganze firma braucht weil es eher so einen proof of concept spielwiesenprojekt
ist habe ich gleich gesagt jungs da sehe ich mich da mache ich mit weil ansonsten bekomme
ich ja da monatelang nicht dazu technik kram zu machen bis alles funktioniert nicht bei allem
bescheid weiß so also wir legen jetzt mal ein eigenes netzwerk an zum ausprobieren was haben
wir denn hier zu bieten das kann man auf zwei arten machen entweder geht man ins webinterface
und sagt hier create weil ich glaube ich muss euch mal plennten weil
die seite ist pro wenn man das ausschaltet das ist aber auch abartig hell das muss
können wir nicht irgendwie so ein zwischending
ja so ist ganz gut oder so ein zwischending nicht super hell
so vielleicht
so vielleicht das andere gefällt man nämlich überhaupt ja ich glaube so ist so ist in ordnung
das ist eine gute idee das ist eine gute idee dass man quasi terraform import sagt das ist
eine gute idee aber nur das was man gesehen hat also man könnte beispielsweise sich ein
netzwerk hier drüber zusammenklicken übers webinterface hier alles mögliche eintragen
am ende sagt man dann ach ja man kann auch bei der gelegenheit gleich firewall regel anlegen
falls man hier welche welche braucht man kann auch einstellen ob es regional sein soll oder global
und dann kann man das erstellen hat natürlich den nachteil ja sowie so wie alles wenn man
es wenn man es von hand macht es ist relativ schlecht reproduzierbar das ist ja auch der
grund warum man sowas wie terraform verwendet wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel ein projekt aufsetzen
will also das ist ja auch das ziel des ganzen wir stellen ein neues projekt und genau wir
stellen ein neues projekt dann soll das hier alles automatisch deployed werden bzw. nicht
deployed provisioniert werden wenn ich es jetzt hier alles von hand anklicken und wegschmeißen
dann muss ich auch wieder alles von hand erzeugen wenn ich das jetzt über terraform erstelle kann
ich entweder über terraform alles wieder löschen lassen oder wenn ich ein neues projekt anlege es
exakt so aufsetzen wie ich es haben will reproduzierbar ohne dass ich jetzt 50 sachen
von hand klicken muss deswegen machen wir tatsächlich das netzwerk erstellen mal über
terraform terraform apply also was würde er machen er würde ein netzwerk erstellen über
den subnet erstellen im prinzip genau das was ich angegeben habe bloß noch mit ein paar sachen die
erst bekannt sind nachdem er das gemacht hat terraform fragt normalerweise immer ob das was
hier steht jetzt auch wirklich gemacht werden soll ist von der idee her ganz sinnvoll weil
das kostet ja potenziell alles geld kostet alles geld hier wenn man was macht also dass
jeder furz jeder furz kostet teilweise geld ja sogar sogar die cloud shell aufmachen das
braucht man nicht die da genau sogar die cloud shell aufmachen das kostet alles geld wobei
ich nicht sicher bin ob es von microsoft oder google war wo die cloud shell geld kostet bei
einem von beiden kosten ich glaube am microsoft kostet die cloud shell geld und bei google ist
sie umsonst bis zu einem gewissen limit könnte aber auch umgedreht kann auch umgedreht sein weiß
gar nicht auf dem kopf nicht zumindest muss man dann bei terraform sagen ja ich möchte das apply
man kann allerdings auch sagen aber dafür gibt es keinen gibt es kein auto complete man kann
allerdings auch sagen glaube ich auto approve war das dann macht er das automatisch das ist
quasi wie wenn ich yes eingegeben hätte vorhin macht er das er erstellt ein netzwerk was wir
übrigens sehen wenn wir hier drauf klicken oder da ist es schon guck wurde angelegt gibt
keine fireball regeln brauchen wir an der stelle noch nicht und irgendwann ist terraform dann
fertig und dann zeige ich euch was cooles an terraform warum man das auch verwendet
oder eines der großen plus punkte halt man es verwendet
fertig der jetzt der hat jetzt das netzwerk angelegt das kann man sich jetzt hier im
angucken was er angelegt hat ip range also subnet subnet ip range 10.10.0.0 slash 24
gateway ip sonst was so wenn man das jetzt aufgebaut hat und mal also mal angenommen es
wären hier mehr als so zwei ressourcen drin am angenommen ich hätte hier 30 verschiedene
sachen angelegt und ich will es jetzt alles wieder los werden dann ist es mit terraform
ganz praktisch auch wenn das nicht immer hundertprozentig funktioniert sollte man
gleich dazu sagen kann man an der stelle sagen terraform destroy dann guckt danach ok in meinem
state file was habe ich denn da und dann kann man sagen terraform destroy und dann fliegt wieder
alles weg was man angelegt hat also ihr werdet gleich sehen jetzt ist wieder rück rückstands
los sofern es denn funktioniert manchmal backt das ein bisschen rum ist wieder alles fort
20 sekunden oder sowas 20 sekunden ist wieder auf geben
also bedenkt so klaut provisioning zeug ist schnell der irt das dauert teilweise ewig
residenz lieber alter ich hätte es nur für netzwerk entfernen
so hat er es geschafft die fresh uns ist jetzt wieder alles rückstandslos weg so
muss das sein in der zeit ist das startup schon bankrott gegangen das ist halt das nice daran
und terraform trägt halt auch den state das heißt wenn jetzt jemand von hand hier was
drinne editiert hätte dann könnte man das auch wieder überschreiben wobei das auch so seine
limitierung hat und man da und man da aufpassen muss also rufen wir das aber noch mal gucken
uns das uns das an snapshots in der google cloud erstellen residenz lieber was hältst du vom
polumi wenn du mich fragst ich mag das mehr als terraform ich verwende jetzt terraform weil
ich auf der arbeit zum größten teil terraform habe und sicherlich nicht schadet sich ein
bisschen mit terraform zu beschäftigen so jetzt haben wir das netzwerk erstellt das
ist wirklich mega residenz lieber jetzt können wir uns auch ein paar andere sachen angucken also
wir haben wir hier unsere app die wir das letzte mal angelegt haben ich klone es mal hier rein
das ist ich werde das danach wieder löschen ich klone das mal hier rein und diese app die macht
nichts weiter als ich kann es euch ja mal zeigen machen wir mal docker bild das hat einen docker
feil drinne und macht nichts anderes wie das komplette ding zu bauen und danach mit dotnet
zu starten also das ist relativ relativ easy also mal docker bild das image bauen da zeige
ich euch mal kurz was die app macht viel simpler geht es nicht
ah ich weiß woran das liegt
ich habe ein kernel update gemacht ich muss rebooten ich habe ein kernel update gemacht ich
muss rebooten deswegen geht das jetzt nicht die fehlermeldung ist natürlich auch wieder
komplett pepega also dass du da also wenn ich die fehlermeldung nicht kennen würde wäre jetzt
wahrscheinlich verzweifelt aber ich weiß das ist so die typische fehlermeldung während er
kann wenn man kernel update gemacht hat wo doch er dann ich nicht mag
firefox wieder aufmachen oder so restore session
so terminal repos ne repos google cloud habe ich das ganze genannt
ich verschreibe mich total oft dicker ihr weiß ich ist ein bisschen blöd aber schreibe
immer doch kein bild guck jetzt funktioniert auch sofort am max ans trinken erinnern sehr gute
idee genau so tanken tanken wir das ganze noch mal das bild cute app latest docker run cute app
jetzt werdet ihr gleich sehen was das macht und zwar moment ich muss noch port 8000 auf 80
was jetzt was diese app macht ist nicht 8000 ist nichts andere
gut
als rum
ah yes excellent alles klar so also diese macht nichts anderes für sinnloses zeug auf
eine webseite ausgeben sonst ist das der entry point stimmt du hast recht logisch
jaja klar das ergibt sinn so und die app macht nichts anderes ist also simple simple demo demo
anwendung und die versuchen mal in die registry zu pushen der netzwerk unser netzwerk ist da
also ihr seht dass das funktioniert richtig gute anwendung also peak
peak anwendungsentwicklung skills so und jetzt kommt das was ich noch nie gemacht habe und
zwar wir brauchen einer kont eine container registry nur mal so zur erklärung was ist
eine container registry beziehungsweise warum braucht man das also machen wir das mal am
beispiel von docker bei kubernetes ist es genau das gleich oder es muss ja nicht mal kubernetes
sein bei docker bei egal welcher container runtime die container runtime muss ja wissen
was sie ausführen soll und dazu gibt man ihr ein image an was ausgeführt werden soll und das
image das container image man nennt es auch ganz gerne umgangssprachlich docker image auch
wenn das korrekt genommen nicht richtig ist muss irgendwo liegen und das image liegt in
einer container registry oder besser gesagt in einer früher hat man gesagt docker registry
ganz korrekt müsste man glaube ich sagen oci registry open nein es ist nicht oracle cloud
infrastructure so will ich schon mal sicher es ist glaube ich open container für was steht
oci noch mal container initiative ja genau open container ich glaube ich glaube ganz korrekt
muss man oci registry umgangssprachlich nennt man das nennt man das docker docker registry
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel sage so was wie docker run ubuntu dann muss das image hier
irgendwo herkommen und das image kommt aus einer container registry die standard container registry
die bei docker eingestellt ist oder die viele standardmäßig verwenden ist docker hub wenn man
jetzt hier zum beispiel mal nach ubuntu sucht wird man feststellen da kommt man da official image
ubuntu das ist das was ich gerade installiert habe kann ich euch auch zeigen hier steht zum
beispiel drinne was ist was es für tags gibt nehmen wir jetzt mal zum beispiel hier jami
auf den auf den jeweiligen tag und es funktioniert wir schmeißen mal kurz alles wieder weg und wenn
ich meine eigenen anwendung laufen lassen will als container sei es jetzt lokal mit docker alter
oder aber auch in einem kubernetes klasser dann muss ich ein container image bauen davon das kann
ich zum beispiel machen mit docker bild es gibt aber auch noch andere tools mit denen man das
machen kann und ich muss es in eine container registry pushen und wenn ich anwendungen habe
die ich nicht der öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen will beziehungsweise auch nicht will dass
die leute die container images pullen können dann kann ich schon mal kein public docker hub repo
benutzen ich könnte die private container registry benutzen bei github ich könnte aber auch die
private container registry in der google cloud verwenden und radion tracer dankeschön für den
sub man könnte sich auch eine container registry selber hausen in einem cluster irgendwo so ab
kein ding aber wenn ich eh quasi die runtime für meine container in der google cloud hausen
will bietet es sich an denke ich mal auch die google cloud container registry zu benutzen und
das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus und dann probieren wir mal aus das ganze in google cloud
run oder wie das heißt das habe ich auch noch nie verwendet laufen zu lassen schieben wir was
dazwischen zwischen dem was wir machen wollen gucken wir das image ausgeführt bekommen in
der google cloud das hat das habe ich das habe ich zum beispiel nie benutzt das gar nicht wie das
wie das funktioniert also wir bauen erst mal wieder den image nämlich von unserer app
moin cross maus so wir bauen image von unserer app das haben wir gerade schon gemacht aber ich
habe gerade meine docker images alle gelöscht schlau wie ich war und jetzt müssen wir das
ganze pushen standardmäßig werden wir auch gleich sehen und wir werden auch sehen dass
es nicht funktioniert standardmäßig macht man das mit docker push wenn ich docker push verwende
sagt er aber also ja cute cute ab dann will er aber zu docker hab pushen und docker hab ist
nicht die registry die ich verwenden will leider ist es in docker ein bisschen umständlich also
man kann und was heißt umständlich ist es bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ja es wäre natürlich
sinnvoll wenn es hier sowas gebe oder gibt man an in welche registry man pushen will das gibt es
aber nicht damit das funktioniert muss man genau muss man das ding richtig taggen also sprich man
muss dann quasi sagen url von der registry port 9000 sowas sowas in der richtung kann man sagen
und dann würde das funktionieren er versucht das dahin zu pushen aber invalid format ok aber so
ungefähr und dann funktioniert das auch das heißt wir müssen jetzt erstmal eine container registry
anlegen in der google cloud und wenn ich das richtig im hinterkopf habe heißt das nicht
mehr registry sondern es heißt nicht mehr container registry sondern artefakt registry
signiert signiert so deine docker images und oder auf der arbeit schon privat nicht
zumindest hier jetzt wird nix wird nix signiert wobei ich kann mir vorstellen könnte dass die
sogar irgendwie automatisch signieren so wir wollen die artefakt registry enable jo
irgendwann ist es dann enabled
drei stunden später
enable so ich vermute mal man muss sagen create repository das habe ich noch nie gemacht keine
ahnung docker ok registry alter morgen ks warum hat mein brauche mein browser gerade einen
kompletten cpu kern das ist bestimmt der dark reader der dark reader macht den scheiß wieder
ja fuck alter drecksting
es ist der dark der dark reader macht manchmal so komische dinger
also ja container nennen wir es einfach mal so das ist eine docker registry standard was gibt
es hier noch für unterschiede was ist denn wenn andere was applikationen soll das soll das
applikationen heißen ok was ist denn wenn andere applikationen auch mit terraform auf die cloud
zugreifen schmeißen die dann auch alle netzwerke weg oder nur die die mit ihnen direkt erstellt
also das ist folgen ich bin nicht ganz sicher ob ich jetzt verstehe was du meinst aber das
liegt also da kommt normalerweise nicht zu problemen wenn man es richtig macht also es könnte jetzt ja
sein mal angenommen wir hätten das hier in dem github liegen wir hätten unsere unsere terraform
geschichte in dem github liegen und du führst das aus und ich für das aus irgendwie parallel
ja da kommt sich das in die quere deswegen macht man das auch nicht deswegen also das kann man
machen wenn man es richtig macht deswegen muss man sich überlegen wo leg ich mein terraform
statefile hin deswegen sollte man das terraform statefile das ist das wo sich terraform merkt
was es für ressourcen aufgebaut hat was die für ids haben wie die heißen dass es die auch
wieder löschen kann deswegen muss ich mir überlegen wenn ich das mit mehreren leuten zeitgleich
verwenden will wo lege ich mein terraform statefile hin und ich kann euch nicht empfehlen das terraform
statefile in ein git repo zu legen weil du dann im endeffekt genau das problem ist du klonsen
dir das repo inklusive statefile du führst das aus ich führe das aus und im endeffekt passt
nicht mehr zusammen zum beispiel kannst du es auch auf ein e3 nicht e3 s3 du kannst auf ich
weiß gar nicht was die es mittlerweile unterstützt back end back end type brauchen wir weiß gar nicht
was sie mittlerweile alles unterstützen hier available backends law remote also du kannst
es du kannst es zum beispiel dein state auf drei speichern du kannst es anscheinend in der post
class datenbank speichern du kannst es in der alibaba cloud speichern da wollte ich schon immer
man terraform state speichern in der alibaba cloud kannst du es aus irgendwelchen gründen
im komponentes cluster speichern ach nee in einem komponentes secret aber im cluster ok warum auch
immer auf dem webserver auf google cloud storage also ich persönlich finde es drei ganz nice da
musste ich nicht um locking oder irgendwelche geschichten dir gedanken machen und dann
funktioniert das also sprich du sagst dem dass dein state beispielsweise auf in einem
in einem s3 storage liegt und dann kannst du und ich das parallel ausführen und das kommt
sich auch nicht in die quere so weit die theorie zumindest ja genau so dass das das
was ligand schreibt so ist das genau so also container ist hier anlegen docker standard
region region wollen wir haben europe west 3 description keckel das muss er ordentlich benutzen
so ok man kann und kann das verschlüsseln von innen
was ist das hier zum beispiel remote
da kann man was zünden von irgendeinem anderen ja leute ist ja gut regt euch ab regt euch ab
was ist was ist jetzt los wurden wir geradet wer hat uns denn geradet haben wir was übersehen
dankeschön für den rate ich weiß immer noch nicht ob man nicht jv peak oder jv peak oder
wie soll man das hat wie spricht man nicht eigentlich richtig aus dankeschön für den
rate ja war ja sag einfach ja ja dann dann vielleicht so besser also ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass er großer ja war fern ist was ich bisher gesehen habe und beides die coolen
leute natürlich auch java aussprechen ja also wir basteln heute ein bisschen nur mal kurz
als erklärung für alle die dabei gekommen sind wir basteln heute ein bisschen in der google
hat zwei hintergründe das erste ist ich habe noch nicht so viel mit google cloud gemacht ich habe
in der vergangenheit hauptsächlich verwendet beim alten arbeitgeber aber macht gut viel viel
erfolg im baumarkt aber ich habe seit erstem april einen neuen job ich habe gekündigt quasi
letzte letztes jahr im december und da hatte ich kündigungs fristplan zumindest jetzt zum
1. april habe ich angefangen und dort wo ich jetzt angefangen habe verwenden sie hauptsächlich
google cloud und ich habe zwar schon in der vergangenheit ein bisschen was google
cloud mäßiges gemacht ich glaube sogar wir haben im stream schon mal ein bisschen google
cloud gemacht oder haben wir da äscher gemacht ich weiß es gar nicht mehr und deswegen dachte
ich mir das ist ein guter anlass mal ein paar sachen in der google cloud auszuprobieren und
sich damit ein paar sachen vertraut zu machen weil ich glaube ich was was ich im stream machen kann
und was was ich auf der arbeit gebrauchen kann und umgedreht was ich auf der arbeit gelernt habe kann
ich dann wieder im stream irgendwann mal erzählen also es bietet sich bietet sich irgendwie an das
ziel für heute ist eigentlich relativ relativ simpel und relativ naheliegend wir wollen ein
paar sachen professionieren in in der google cloud wir wollen es einen container registry anlegen
paar docker images reinpushen können da netzwerke anlegen das haben wir tatsächlich schon gemacht
dann mal eine vm anlegen ob ich den den kubernetes cluster heute anlege weiß ich nicht zumindest
würde ich gerne über terraform noch eine postkurs datenbank in der google cloud professionieren
weil dann können wir im nächsten stream weitermachen eine beispiel anwendung deployen und am ende das
ganze in dem kuban im dritten stream oder so dazu das ganze in dem kubanetiskluster laufen lassen
wo wir das dann auch alles tatsächlich mal ganz ordentlich machen werden so mit infrastruktur
git repo service mesh für verschlüsselung mit mtls unter den pots bzw innerhalb des clusters mit
einem cloud load balancer als eingang da lassen wir dann eine kleine testanwendung laufen die
wir hier im nächsten stream dann zusammen bauen ja aber jetzt bin ich gerade dabei mir eine
container registry zu erzeugen das habe ich nämlich noch nicht gemacht und gucken ob ich
kann wie ist der erste eindruck von google cloud also ich habe ja vorher schon ein bisschen was
gemacht mit google cloud ich muss sagen ich finde da nix ich finde es total undurchsichtig wo da
was ist das ist bei asia auch so aber bei asia weiß ich mittlerweile wo was ist google hat ich
zeige euch das mal wenn ihr hier draufklickt sieht ihr erst mal sieht ihr erst mal relativ
übersichtlich aus gär das passt mal auf
und das das ist auch das ist auch alles wenn ihr wenn es mal richtig richtig unordentlich haben wollt
so und jetzt und jetzt finde mal was du suchst ja ok es ist aber es ist aber tatsächlich meistens
halb so wild weil man mit den meisten sachen mit den meisten sachen massive rate weil man mit
den meisten sachen hier oben halbwegs halbwegs zurecht kommt die sachen die sachen sind meist
noch recht selbsterkläger also nur mal so ganz ganz kurze ganz kurze übersicht ist eigentlich
egal hier kann man sich angucken wie die abrechnung aussieht ist eigentlich der wichtigste ja die
suchleiste wenn du weißt was du suchst das ist übrigens auch ein großer unterschied zu aws ich
finde die dinger bei google cloud sind deutlich besser benannt als aws muss aber sagen ich habe
mit aws noch von allen drei großen cloud anbietern bisher das wenigste gemacht aber ich finde bei
aws sind die dinger wirklich total hängen geblieben benannt ich meine wie kommt man auf die idee das
fahre geht irgendwas mit mannage kubernetes zu tun hat also die benahmung bei aws ist echt
absolut krass ppeger oder was gab es noch aws snow snow mobile aws snow mobile das ist wenn
ihr wollt dass amazon zu euch den lkw schickt muss mal kurz hier achtung flashbang wenn ihr
wollt dass amazon zu euch den lkw schickt dann braucht ihr aws snow mobile apache klingt auch
instant nach webserver ja das ist aber schon so alt und so bekannt es kann man sich mittlerweile
merken ja hat aber auch nicht den schönsten namen aber nginx auch also viele sachen heißen ja nicht
wie das was es ist aber bei einem cloud anbieter hättest du die chance ist irgendwie so zu nennen
ja was machen sie aber nicht ich finde bei google cloud sind die dinger ganz gut benannt also
amazon wenn ihr wirklich peter beidweiser die festplatten gestapelt habt bei euch und die
sollen zu google india zu amazon in die cloud da könnt ihr euch aws snow mobile bestellen da
kommen die mit einem lkw zu euch gefahren und nehmen die festplatten mit oder vielleicht hat
der truck auch ein usb stecker und man kann die sachen per usb upload ich bezweifle es
habe ich jetzt habe ich jetzt mein leute war ich jetzt so blöd und habe das das das erstellen
von meiner registry wieder zugemacht weil ich bescheuert bin baumarkt bis denn
ja das ist eigentlich auch so der erste eindruck von google cloud total kompliziert wo was steht
aber die dinger sind halbwegs brauchbar benannt ja ok also ich wollte mir eine container registry
anlegen eine sorry keine container registry macht nicht den gleichen fehler wie ich vorhin fast ihr
wollt keine container registry auch wenn ihr eine container registry wollt so viel zum thema wieder
gut benannt ja ihr wollt keine container registry ihr wollt ein eine artifact registry warum weil
container registry alt legacy und deprecated ist und artefakt registry der neueste shit
create repository container alter ich muss den dark reader ausmachen ich raste aus
wie beschissen möchte eine software eigentlich noch noch werden soll heute ich muss euch leider
flash bang mein dark reader macht 100 prozent cpu auslastung für den browser
container so wir wollen eine docker registry haben auch wenn es streng genommen nicht stimmt
dass eine docker registry ist das ist written in javascript ja da kann ich schiefgehen so region
zu region muss man in google cloud wissen muss ich umgedreht sagen zu zonen und regionen muss
man in google cloud wissen es gibt zeige euch das mal kurz es gibt mehrere unterregionen von
einer region das nennt sich dann zone ja zum beispiel gibt es europe west 3 europe west 3
ist quasi frankfurter mein warum es nicht europe ffm heißt keine ahnung wahrscheinlich dass sie
sich die option offen halten es umzuziehen nach köln oder so und es trotzdem weiter europe west
3 heißt aber europe west 3 ist in frankfurt doch registry mit terraform anlegen machen wir
da ich will erst mal von hand gucken und unterhalb von so einer region gibt es noch verschiedene
zonen es gibt zum beispiel die region west 3 gibt es drei unterregionen und abc und ihr müsst
ein bisschen gucken wenn ihr ressourcen in der google cloud anlegt manchmal gibt es so was wie
location was man anlegen kann und bei location könnt ihr manchmal eine region reinschreiben
oder eine zone reinschreiben und wenn ihr eine region reinschreibt dann neigen manche
sachen dazu sich zu replizieren also sprich wenn ihr zum beispiel ein kubernetes cluster erstellt
in der region europe west 3 dann legt er diese ganze kubernetes control plane legt er dreimal
an nämlich in europe west 3 abc wenn ihr das nicht wollt müsst ihr in location eine zone angeben
das kann cool sein mit dem replizieren wenn man das braucht es kann aber auch doof sein wenn man
einen storage quota hat von 250 gigabyte wie ich hier bei meinem test account und es dann einfach
nicht funktioniert was willst du in google cloud machen ich will eine container registry anlegen
netzwerke anlegen eine vm anlegen kubernetes cluster anlegen eine cloud postgres datenbank
anlegen und das ganze mit terraform provisionieren damit ich dann im nächsten stream eine testanwendung
bauen kann die wir später im dritten stream auf unserer kubernetes cluster deployen können und
das ordentlich machen so sieht es aus das wenn ihr dabei sein wollt leute jetzt muss ich ein
bisschen sehr laut machen weil sind jetzt paar neue leute dazugekommen wenn ihr dabei sein wollt
ich kann euch aber nicht versprechen dass es exakt die aufeinander folgende nächsten zwei
streams sein werden ihr könnt ihr jetzt ja folgen und wieder reingucken so also
container registry anlegen blablabla lassen wir mal alles default sieht eigentlich alles gut aus
jetzt muss ich mal gucken wie man in diese container registry reinpushen kann weil da
bin ich jetzt echt ein bisschen planlos und ich muss den da krüder wieder anmachen das
mir einfach zu zu hart der kontrast
format go ja du kannst go sachen darin darin hosten es ist aber nicht es ist aber nicht so viel es
gibt ja noch deutlich mehr ruby gems zum beispiel ok wen interessieren ruby gems heutzutage noch
oder pipp oder sowas gibt es hier auch nicht da kommen wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr dabei
gut wir haben unsere container registry angelegt und jetzt ist die große preisfrage
wie
pushe ich was in die container registry rein echt stand ran habe ich nicht gesehen habe ich
nicht gesehen hatte google hier neben nicht mal so eine hilfe so eine hilfeanzeige die sowas immer
immer eingepländet hat so so nach dem motto möchten sie nicht sich jetzt mit der registry
verbinden haben wir das wieder einpländen lassen setup instructions ok dann das ok
gcloud authentifizieren konfigure docker ok ich hoffe ich liege jetzt nix weil wenn ich jetzt
was liege muss jetzt wieder löschen ok sieht sieht sieht nicht so aus als hätte ich irgendwelche
jetzt haben wir unsere lokalen docker konfiguriert dass er wahrscheinlich für einen push in die
container registry die hier konfigurierten zugangsdaten benutzt ich vermute mal dass
er die zugangsdaten von meinem google cloud utility verwendet denke ich mal so und wie
macht man wie benutzt man das jetzt artifact registry push ja zeige ich schon mal her wie
macht man das push and pull images artifact registry documentation was will der von mir
kein ex ist tauschen pushing an image tagging the local image location
ok also ich vermute mal ok mal mal mal docker image bild so
was the fuck
bau bau wir das mal so
ok was auch immer so location is
location is europe west europe west 3 docker punkt
deaf minus docker nee oder das das kommt wieder weg docker project id project id hat immer stream
das ist meine project id also ich kann gerade echt nicht tippen stream 38 38 11 repository name das
dürfte hoffe ich mal dürfte dass die container registry sein und die heißt container und das
image heißt cute app latest das probieren wir jetzt maus will ich nicht speichern bild tag
cute app latest failed to resolve ach so ich bin im falschen verzeichen ok das scheint funktioniert
zu haben und jetzt mache ich wie wie geht's weiter wie kriege ich mein docker image da rein docker
push ok einfach das gleiche noch einmal docker push latest nein das funktioniert nicht
die night on resource container und mehr oder x ist ok was habe ich falsch gemacht
irgendwas irgendwas habe ich falsch gemacht doch kein login nee brauche ich nicht ich brauche
kein docker login das habe ich hier vorhin schon gemacht der benutzt der benutzt die
über meine google google command line tool habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht europe west minus
docker sieht doch eigentlich gut aus oder
cacquard
tonight or resource
could not open configuration file
ist es jetzt gut oder schlecht
ok das habe ich ja eben schon gemacht
ok ja keine ahnung warum das nicht funktioniert
hatte tps davor nicht glaube nicht glaube nicht zumal es sogar sogar die
folgt ist hatte tps du kannst es bei doch glaube ich gar nicht unterdrücken
direkt von der kommandozeit ok das funktioniert nicht was ist was ist hier
was ist hier verkehrt googeln wir mal danach ja benutze ich benutze ich da ist es
permissions denied artefakt denied ok warum
i'm trying to push ok aha
das ist der einzige user den es gibt und als admin user
ok ich habe ich habe hier bestimmt irgendwas bestimmt verkehrt es ist
meine ist meine projekt id richtig stream 3811
das ist richtig dass du so mal kurz die hilfe angucken tag so ist ja location docker den
projekt id repository ich vermute mal nee ich muss mich nicht
autentifizieren das geht über das google google cloud cli guck über das über das hier
oben your config file add wissen was ich lösche das mal ich lösche mal kurz mein mein docker
config weiß ja nie und jetzt sagen wir noch mal yes
could not open config file configuration config default ist vielleicht das das
ich kann hier davon kann ich halt hier im stream nichts öffnen ich meine ich kann mal die
das wo kommt das projekt her das ist die projekt id von dem google cloud project also das müsste
eigentlich doch stimmen was passiert wenn ich irgendwas eintrage was es hier gar nicht gibt
also dann gibt es das nicht hier bauern bild europe europe west
hier das gibt es gar nicht ja dann weiß ich auch nicht wo das das problem ist
europe west doch irgendwie habe ich irgendwo verschrieben
projekt id darf ich das vielleicht nicht container nennen
man kann es doch sogar hier kopieren man kann es doch sogar hier kopieren
so da war ein doppelte ich weiß verabsicht
probier doch mal ghcr
warum sollte ich es nach github pushen
so was komplett anderes ok vielleicht hat mein user aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht
genug rechte warum auch immer das standardmäßig so sein sollte beim einzigen user der admin
berechtigung jetzt ist doch ein neuer fehler eines exakter exakter gleiche fehler von von vorhin
so was könnte das problem sein in ischgl tata i was able to recreate
and i will try to push an image on a river in which it's specific is not yet added to critter
hat
ja schon gemacht das das habe ich doch das habe ich auch schon gemacht ja das habe ich
das europe west 3 habe ich auch schon gemacht
ist denn das problem jetzt
das habe ich genau das habe ich doch gemacht
update cloud components ist doch auch blödsinnig warum warum soll ich den graben updaten ich
habe wahrscheinlich habe ich nicht konnte man open the config fallen glaube ich nicht
ok vielleicht muss man bei google cloud das kann sein dass man bei google cloud
irgendwie default project setzen muss bei asia muss man das machen
aber das doch mal
project id stream ob es jetzt geht
jetzt ist die jetzt ist die fehlermeldung weg aber es geht immer noch nicht
doch doch also was könnten das ich habe die ja ich meine ich habe die anleitung ja genauso
gemacht wie es sein soll
gehen wir noch mal in die registry rein cloud in it
er sonst würde das hier gar nicht funktionieren
warum habe ich das überhaupt dann alles habe ich am anfang nicht cloud in it gemacht
ne habe ich doch wir können es reinitialisieren warum nicht
dann du musst lock in to continue what you like to lock in yes aber nicht da drinne sondern da
yes yes
pick pick cloud project to use ions do you want to configure default compute region or zone
ok in it in it vorhin war wahrscheinlich nicht in it genug aber jetzt pusht da meine
meine images auf jeden fall schon mal rauf habe ich das nicht vorhin gemacht ich habe ich habe
mich ich habe das kann das sein dass ich das in it irgendwie geskippt habe im kopf und direkt
die alternifizierung gemacht habe ok das ergibt natürlich sinn wenn das alles noch nicht da war
ok so also jetzt ist mein image da ja da ist es doch da ist mein image alles klar nice wunderbar
so jetzt machen wir was was ich heute eigentlich nicht machen wollte und zwar das habe ich keine
ahnung wie das funktioniert es gibt doch so was wie cloud run noch nie ausprobiert oder cloud run
wie heißt der kram hier cloud run serverless for containerized applications da kann man wenn
man container image hat das einfach ausführen ohne kubernetes cluster ohne irgendwas das das
probieren einfach mal aus der richtig pepega jeder da wieder man warum haben die denn kein
native warum haben warum haben die kein native dark sieben einfach run containers on a fully
managable das probieren jetzt einfach mal aus kein plan aber gucken wir mal enable cloud run admin
api container image url gut ich hoffe mal dass ich was von meiner eigenen registry auswählen kann
high speed google cloud was no images were found
ok damit hat sich das schon mal erledigt würde ich sagen
lernmoor habe ich das falsch gepusht
meinetwegen cloud project id ja das brauchen wir nicht das haben wir alle schon gemacht
also es kann durchaus sein dass ich das dass sich das überhaupt nicht dafür eignet ja
ist ist es durchaus möglich dass ich mein image gar nicht dafür eignet weil ich irgendwas
habe ich überhaupt nicht vorgehabt das ist einfach nur langsam einfach nur lahm es fragt
ja cute ab latest einfach nur langsam ok die pläne von revision from an existing container image
kontinuos die deploy new revisions from a source repos oder ist ja noch cooler da macht
er automatisch in der neue version die cloud bill will ich nicht macht das selbst name oh man der
dark reader alter ich sorry leute ich muss euch ich muss euch flash bang google cloud funktioniert
mit dem dark reader nicht tut nicht kontinuos die pläne cute ab in iowa genau da wollte ich
unbedingt hin europe europe 3 frankfurt ach nee das geht gar nicht ja ja ich dachte der
wenn ich eine neue revision gepusht habe das war jetzt nicht gar nicht eigentlich mein ziel
aber will man das image mal aus erst select cpu allocation and pricing cpu is only allocated
ja gut das ist die geschichte mit cold cold start zeit und so was wahrscheinlich also
vermute ich man man sieht es hier zwar nicht richtig aber ich gehe mal davon aus dass der
nicht permanent das image laufen lässt sondern erst wenn es requests gibt spart geld aber der
erste request nach einer zeit in aktivität dauert ein bisschen ach hier minimum instances
null mini ok wenn man minimum instances eins machen dann ist immer einer da
machen wir mal mal mal mal null mal gucken set to want to reduce cold starts
ah ja steht ja sogar unten drunter naja lassen was machen wir machen wir mal eins ok
internal knee all allow direct access from internet authentication
allow unauthorized ja container network security wir lassen es wir lassen es einfach mal brauchen
auch keine keine zertifikate und sonstige dinge create das habe ich wirklich nie ausprobiert
das ist der einfachste die einfachste variante in der google cloud container images laufen zu
lassen das auf jeden fall brauchst kein managed kubernetes kein autopilot kubernetes oder sonst
was einfach container gib ihm fertig container port anpassen das ist glaube ich port 80 standard
mäßig bei mir weiß ich nicht ob ach hier port 80 80 dann wird es wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren
ja dann wird es wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren ok gucken wir gleich mal
erst mal kurz checken wie lange er überhaupt braucht das ganze das ganze zu deployen
refreshen wir mal ok da braucht noch ein bisschen enable clue
wahrscheinlich braucht er beim ersten mal ein bisschen länger postchamp
keck btf wie viele keck channel wie viele keck emotes icka icka mache ich rein finde ich nicht
schlecht wie viel wollen wir da eigentlich noch machen manches ist wirklich abartig langsam
residenz sleeper
pending
kann es sein dass das einfach nur so lange braucht weil ich den port nicht richtig angegeben
habe kann man es jetzt noch mal nachträglich ändern
edit and deploy new revision ok genau ok das ist gut container port 80
rest bleibt add cloud sql connections das ist natürlich auch sehr nice dass man das hier
direkt direkt drüber machen kann ohne irgendwie secrets injecten und sonst was
unter der haube wird es wahrscheinlich auch ein kubernetes sein aber das ist
halt die mit abstand einfachste variante networking ok jetzt haben wir port 80
was haben wir eingetragen port hier tcp 80 container port 80 ok hat es ja so was
ich gar nicht ja ja ja ja die haben auch so was ich weiß aber grad gar nicht wie es heißt die
haben auch so was heißt das nicht heisten das container workload heißt es nicht einfach nur
container workload bei azure app funtions ja das klingt gut das klingt gut app funtions das gibt's
jetzt ist die app da ok nice und die alte konvolution actions delete delete bamm das ist
zack neue neue app am start alles klar so cute app postchamp postchamp
erster request kann ein bisschen dauern
erster request kann ein bisschen dauern vielleicht eine blöde idee dass ich das alte jetzt
abgeschaltet habe bei der gelegenheit können wir mal alle tabs to the right
aber was macht das 3 stunden da darf man das überhaupt löschen
aber wohl ein krasses delay
ja ich weiß dass es fail to start ist
braucht das so lange service unavailable keine ahnung
ok leute ich habe keine ahnung was ich hier getrieben habe ich lösche das ich lösche
das ding jetzt noch mal und legt es noch mal an keine ahnung was er für schmerzen hat
ach das war ohne htps nicht das das ich würde ich würde eigentlich erwarten wenn ich auf den link
klicke dass es ein automatisches redirect hat wir legen wir legen es einfach noch mal
neu an ok also select keine ahnung was ich verkehrt gemacht habe wahrscheinlich wird
es einfach da ein paar minuten schon funktionieren cute ab dass da will ich haben select nein nicht
us central komm wir gehen jetzt mal nach europe nach tier 1 pricing ist tier 1 pricing besser
als tier 2 pricing oder ist was ist also für mich ist besser was billiger ist
gehen wir nach belgien minimum instances machen wir 1 allow ja ok und und container
container port müssen wir noch ändern container port 80 ja ok schaue ob es jetzt funktioniert
das sollte an sich ja eigentlich relativ schnell gehen networking container port completed ok
und den pol 80 ok angeblich läuft alles das immer doch ok irgendwas irgendwas habe ich
verkackt das ist nur wirklich mit abstand der einfachste wege irgendwelche apps in
der google class um laufen zu bringen wenn man sie kontinuerisiert hat da braucht man
kein mannatsch kopane des klasse und nix kostet aber wahrscheinlich auch am meisten vermute ich
jetzt einfach mal natürlich ist die domain für den arsch ja cute ab ewe punkt ab punkt
rand punkt ab komplett unbrauchbare url aber man könnte natürlich das weiß ich nicht wie es
geht das machen wir dann auch im hier in diesem stream irgendwann gucken wie ich die domain
umgebogen bekommen auf google cloud wahrscheinlich muss ich einfach zu meinem registrar gehen und
sagen die google cloud dns servers sind jetzt dafür zuständig würde ich jetzt mal würde ich
jetzt mal vermuten ok interessant das hat funktioniert jetzt auch wenn ich das nicht
ausprobieren wollte ist auf jeden fall ein nicer service wenn man einfach mal zackig was bereit
stellen will wir probieren wir probieren mal kurz was aus und zwar gehen wir hier in die app und
wir ändern mal irgendwas hier program cs und da kommt jetzt einfach einfach 123 kommt einfach
weg so dann bauen wir das container image bild latest pushen das pushen das container image
und jetzt ok noch noch ist es die alte app und jetzt sagen wir edit and deploy new revision
gehe ich mal von aus und select latest hier wo wir die haben alles jetzt richtig ein ja
obviously das wird schon richtig sein wie guck mal wie mies das gemacht ist der wählt
ja nicht noch mal aus so container port 80 cpu allocation die blu man sieht schon der erste
ok das ist wirklich einfach also wenn ich irgendwas vercontainerisiertes hätte was
ich einfach nur irgendwo laufen lassen will dann ist der service wirklich easy
unter der haupe wird es wahrscheinlich auch in kuba nades cluster sein aber halt komplett
von google das ist cool das gefällt mir also mein ziel für übernächsten stream ist dass
wir selbst in kuba nades cluster machen wo wir das drin laufen lassen
stimmt google hat ja ihren eigenen kuba nades vorgänger quasi mit eingebautem load balancer
wir verwenden den cloud balancer wahrscheinlich ich bin mir noch gar nicht sicher wobei wir können
auch den ingress verbinden mit unserem service mesh weiß ich noch nicht genau wie was machen
ok also das also cloud run ist tatsächlich richtig simpel übrigens chat ihr könnt ja mal ausprobieren
das bei euch müsste die seite auch funktionieren ja guck mal probiert mal aus die sollte bei euch
genauso gehen wie bei mir wenn ihr die aufmacht sollte die auf den gleichen auf den gleichen
jetzt probieren wir mal was aus wir machen mal wir machen mal ein bisschen wir machen mal ein
bisschen last würde ich sagen gucken wir uns gucken wir uns das ganze mal an wir machen mal
ein bisschen last und zwar nicht zwei millionen requests lasst mal kurz gucken nicht zwei millionen
requests das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben du wolltest du nicht übertreiben
minus z ist was duration of applications to send requests
duration war eine minute eine minute war übrigens eine minute und nicht eine millionen requests
ja das ist ich will jetzt ich will jetzt nicht gar gar überkommen geben zu viel das ist zu viel
aber jetzt irgendwas ich will zu ich will zu rate ich will zu rate limited haben
ich will zwei minuten das ist schon ok ok 200 response
rate limit rate limit
yew right limit in kurz per second per worker wie viel ist da stand natlich
worker numbers 2 und rate limit 200 pro 100 ok 10 pro sekunde reicht glaube ich
was jetzt verkehrt ah moment
ok jetzt jetzt sollte ein paar requests reinkommen ja wir wollen es ja nicht übertreiben
request request counts view chart in fullscreen übertreibst halt man ok view chat in fullscreen
if viele requests haben wir jetzt ein request die sekunde
startet aber aus
so ich will jetzt eigentlich nur mal gucken ob der irgendwie rauf skaliert ja ich muss die
zeit request ich will gucken ob der irgendwie rauf skaliert jetzt
google cloud functions ist doch aber nicht für container workloads sondern für direkt
also quasi functions also direkt source code ausführen und nicht erst vercontainerisieren
5 requests zeit für eine stunde ich hätte es gerne ein bisschen
jetzt gerne ein bisschen schneller aber geht anscheinend nicht
wo konnte ich jetzt noch mal was neues deployen hier so und wo sehe ich jetzt wie viel wie viel
er da skaliert hat von sloth also immer logs
firefox hey da das bin ich so revisions sieht man da irgendwo wie viele wie viele er aktuell
laufen hat weil ich habe ja eingestellt dass er von eins container instance count hier oder wo
ane hier instance ach ja ok 2 er hat ok er hat jetzt eine hochgefahren ok leute wir machen mal
wir geben ihm mal ein bisschen mehr
wir machen zehn mal so viel komm gib ihm 10 worker und 20 requests pro sekunde also haben
200 200 requests die sekunde gerade und hier haben wir instance ok das sollte vielleicht
gleich hoch skalieren ja es geht rauf view in matrix explorer ja das ist so ein ding so was
hatten die in so was gibt es in azure auch in azure haben die noch so eine komische query
language dafür weiß ich ob google auch so was hat ne die haben nur so ein bilder ne hier code
die haben auch so was ja das war übelst kompliziert aber auch ganz nice auf der anderen
seite ich persönlich ich finde es immer noch nice wenn man das irgendwie in kraft ane rein
kriegt kann man hier einstellen dass der auto refreshed ich will nicht absolut time ranges
ich will die letzten letzten 15 minuten ist gut auto refresh kann man nicht so was machen wie
hier kann man nicht die zeit ich wollte ich wollte die letzte minute dass ich schön sehe
wie es hoch geht ok es hier gab es zwischenzeitlich ein paar vierhunderter
gibt man eine ach du ach man kann hier oben ja auch tatsächlich was eingeben
last minute ok two minutes war gar nicht fünf minutes jetzt geht er jetzt geht er
wieder runter auf irgendwie fünf requests die sekunde stand nicht eine minute als ich
habe es ich habe es nicht gesehen wo denn ach hier das ist aggregieren über eine minute
ja gut das muss ja irgendwie das passt schon das ist das ist in ordnung das ist in ordnung so
jetzt jetzt geben wir immer jetzt geben wir immer ordentlich 1000 1000 requests
oder warum wollen wir mal so schnell wie geht
wollen wir mal so schnell wie geht und gucken was es uns am ende kostet
aber ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt so schnell ist wie geht
also ich weiß nicht wie viele requester macht wir hätten uns am ende angucken müssen
wie viele instanzen hat er jetzt gestartet nur zwei ok ok jetzt geht es hoch jetzt gehen die
requests ok war so immer spiel spielerei aber es ist wenn man einfach nur was verkontinerisiert
hat und laufen lassen will ist es wirklich nicht schlecht mich würde es halt mal interessieren
was es kostet im endeffekt sollte das nicht hochgehen sollte das jetzt nicht eigentlich
rauf gehen 213
ja das sieht schon besser aus
ja kann mir einer diese logik erklären wie das geht
ich blick den graf nicht das hier das hier ergibt das hier ergibt schon deutlich mehr
sinn also wir haben 900 wir haben ungefähr 90.000 90.000 anfragen gemacht davon waren
8997 ok 44 44 nicht ok wir haben 749 requests pro sekunde gemacht was hier absolut sich nicht
drinne niederschlägt also das ist ziemlich doch ein bisschen das ist ziemlich zeitverzögert so
was kostet was kostet mich das jetzt eigentlich was würde mich das jetzt kosten
ich glaube ich war noch im free tier drinne
requests per second über die letzte stunde dass jetzt einfach eine stunde requests schicken
keck ich meine mehr als 288 euro kann ich ausgeben ok nice
weißt du was sein kann kann sein dass mich google band google google cloud mäßig wenn
ich zu zu sehr rumsperme mit requests ich meine sind requests auf den auf den gültigen web service
das ergibt eigentlich keinen sinn es ergibt eigentlich kann sie nehmen lassen es mal laufen
aber guck wir sind schon auf 3 73 requests hoch ja aber ok wie würde ich denn jetzt
sehen was es mich kostet das ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen oh ja guck mal leute
sind wir bei 2,5.000 2,5.000 requests die sekunde
und das skaliert ja auch ordentlich hoch stonks
wollen wir mal gucken ob wir irgendwie rauskriegen billing ob wir irgendwie rauskriegen was uns das
jetzt kosten würde ich habe seriously keinen plastenschimmer wie man das hier raus bekommt
das ist meistens ein bisschen zeitversetzt ok keine ahnung
keine ahnung wie man das hier rausbekommt das ist aber auch bei allen cloud anbietern
unglaublich schwierig rauszubekommen was es eigentlich kostet ob das ist alles absicht
die die wollen die wollen das möglichst möglichst undurchsichtig haben dass man
feed dass man mehr ausgibt als als man denkt set up continuous deployment was macht das
repository provider nee nee nee ich dachte also ist ja was cool wäre wenn das ding
es wäre cool wenn das ding nachgucken könnte es wurde neues image gepusht und dann die pläuter
ist neu der muss das das image musste ja nicht unbedingt bauen und in git repo bräuchte dafür
eigentlich auch nicht aber ich glaube das konnte man nicht nee das konnte man nicht einsteigen
bitt backet
klaut und ist klaut source das githab gegenstück von von google
benutzt benutzt das irgendjemand
ich möchte es nicht benutzen müssen ja
wie wird das in rechnung gestellt das stand das stand da wie das jetzt steht auch da klaut
ran hier check pricing tears das das gibt es per request und per genau das wird auf
request basis auf bandbreiten basis auf cpu time basis wird das berechnet also diese drei
sachen ergeben dann was es im endeffekt kostet pricing calculator ja gucken wir mal gucken
wir mal was es kosten würde nur mal eine theorie was was würde es kosten okay wir wollen ein
es gehört das zu compute engine nee klaut ran ein resource ein job name of the service ja gut
es ist egal wie es heißt location europe cpu is only allocated during request processing glaub
das haben wir ich glaube wir haben die standard sachen minibom number ich glaube 80 ist jeder
default konkurrent request per instance müssen wir mal nachgucken
nee wo stand da kram revisions hier konkurrenz 80 und 10 okay läuft das service noch minimum
number of instance 1 konkurrent request 80 execution time per request tja das kann ich in
meinen metrics gucken metrics execution time per millisekunde oder so ganz wenig
container instance was ist meine request time stand es da nicht irgendwo hier
irgendwie sowas 2 2 millisekunden haben wir 2 millisekunden pro request
aber 2 millisekunden per request request per month ja wie viele request per month haben wir
denn wie kann man das jetzt hochrechnen wir haben gerade okay ganz einfach wir haben gerade
ein request die stunde also 246 request pro sekunde haben wir gerade und aktuell haben wir
okay aktuell haben wir der graph ist kaputt alter video in fullscreen
okay man aber das hier aktuell aber 1500 request pro sekunde okay chat clickmaps 1500
requests pro sekunde sind so sind 90.000 requests in der minute sind was auch immer
pro stunde mache ich das richtig requests pro
tag mal 30 okay nice oh das wird teuer leute sage ich euch
ja geht doch eigentlich das geht eigentlich geht das voll klar 1500 dollar
1444 euro das geht doch eigentlich voll klar
moment eine datas entfernt geht auch eigentlich voll klar oder
ja nee ich finde das voll ich finde das wirklich in ordnung ich mein das ist schon ordentlich
also konstant konstant 1500 request die sekunde muss da auch erst mal erst mal hinkriegen ja
ich finde das auch okay ich mein konstant über 1000 request die sekunde welche seite
welche also wie man so als normalsterblicher betreibt hat den so was ist bescheuert ich will
ich google und zeug die haben natürlich wahrscheinlich noch mehr aber 2000 wie weiter mit cpus kommst
ja das hat er sich ja ausgerechnet ich habe ihm mal gesagt es dauert zwei millisekunden pro
request am ende ist es wahrscheinlich trotzdem doch mal teurer
memory reicht ja offensichtlich memory reicht ja sonst wird es jetzt ja auch abschmieren
also ich schon ich habe so was naja gut so aber bevor ich jetzt wirklich hier irgendwie das mein
free tier aufbrauche beenden wir das mal an der stelle wieder aber das war schon mal interessant
da sind wir was gelernt also ganz im ernst das ist tatsächlich auch bei uns auf der arbeiten option
würde ich sagen ich meine überlegt man die wollen ja im prinzip nur in anführung strichen
1 2 simple container zusätzlich laufen lassen das braucht ja oder 3 container oder so was
insgesamt das braucht ja das muss ja kein kubernetes cluster werden wo drei container
drauf laufen mein praktisch gesehen werden wir es in dem schon bestehenden kubernetes cluster
laufen lassen aber es würde ja eigentlich gar keinen sinn machen
ja klingt auch sinnvoll klingt auch sinnvoll na gut hochverfügbar ist serverless ja auch du
meinst halt 24 7 die laufen die keine cold start time und so was haben ja das würde ich auch von
ausgehen das ist gar nicht mal so übel also ich das also das ist wirklich eine super simple
geschichte um eine app zu deployen wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt noch die domain umgebogen
hätte könntet ihr könntet ihr die da drunter aufmachen so ich lösche das jetzt aber mal wieder
sonst kostet geld weil ich habe ja konstant allocated instances so delete next erst mal
löschen was haben wir als nächstes unsere to do liste also mit container und registry pushen hat
ja das wollte ich noch ausprobieren ich okay das machen wir heute noch eine vm anlegen und mal
gucken kurz wie das mit dem tunneln ist also was ich kenne ist was man machen kann ist ssh verbinden
das ist easy auf eine vm einzelne ports weiter leiten ist auch easy und wenn es jemand für
einen eingerichtet hat in cloud vpn ist auch relativ easy wobei ich das noch nie von hand
eingerichtet habe aber gucken wir ob ich das auf die reihe krieg also gehen wir mal von aus ich
habe hier einen privaten kubernetes cluster und muss mich irgendwie zu dem hin verbinden da muss
man das ja über irgendeinen in den jump post machen also brauchen wir eine vm wobei ich nicht
weiß ob es da nicht sogar andere möglichkeiten mittlerweile gibt hier compute engine vm instances
machen wir mal machen wir mal eine vm
danach machen wir noch eine cloud sql postgres datenbank so in stanzen ist bei admin
europe immer nach frankfurt geben
okay wir dann neue vm anlegen bla bla blub deploy container image aha aha ok compute engine
service account allow full access bm wenn schon so networking wollen wir allerdings nicht das
default networking haben so viel weiß ich schon mal sondern wir wollen es hier an unser angestellt
dass das das würde ich normalerweise jetzt nicht machen weil dann hat terraform wieder
probleme wenn ich hier schon was mitgemacht habe es wieder zu löschen macht es aber trotzdem
subnet 10 100 32 ja die vm preise sind echt jenseits von allem ja so und wir wollen auch
keine public ip hier public ip brauchen wir nicht ok dann ob das passt create
so wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe sollte jetzt irgendwann mal die vm angelegt haben
und dann können wir sowas sagen wie gcloud compute compute sind die ganzen vm vm geschichten das
heißt bei denen so ok ist angelegt aber nur mit einer internen ip ok gcloud compute und ich glaube
jetzt konnte man sagen ssh dann konnte man sagen wie das ding heißen soll und dann war ganz wichtig
das muss ich mir copy pasten die vm hat ja jetzt nur eine interne ip ich muss jetzt quasi über
so einen so einen gateway gehen dass das funktioniert test passphrase keckel bei
hessner 320 vor allem ohne public ip also vms sind google cloud technisch wirklich teuer
aber muss er sagen die kubanete cluster sind auch nicht billig also auf digital
ocean oder so fährt man wenn man rein man hat kubanete es braucht viel viel günstiger als bei
google cloud möchtest du dich heute noch connecten vielleicht zu meiner vm wäre das wäre das denkbar
no pass
warning welches warning genau
ist die vm schon da
moment was was hat er geschrieben
missing firewall ach so ja ich habe das ja gar nicht freigegeben freigegeben stimmt
ingress traffic ach so ok da machen wir das noch das war jetzt nicht über terraform so wir gehen
mit network so das habe ich auch noch nie über das ui gemacht wie geht das hier gehen wir dahin
firewall firewall hier allow incoming allow internal allow default ok allow ssh ist doch
drinne von
kann man das irgendwie editieren müsste doch eigentlich funktionieren oder allow ssh from
anywhere source filters alles sollte das nicht gehen ok was sagt jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken
was hat was erzählt er mir wenn ich ich pass ssh verwendet vor allem is missing firewall allowing
tcp ingress traffic from muss man das explizit angeben ich dachte eigentlich dass das alles
naja gut legen wir was an wie legt man hier was an firewall policies refresh create firewall
firewall policy firewall rule firewall rule wollen wir wahrscheinlich anlegen oder was sagt
er hier missing firewall rule also namen ja ssh es klopfte logs brauchen wir nicht die
fortnetwork das da firewall bei der vm ich wüsste nicht dass auf vm ebene
irgendwie starrt mich was geblockt wird
glaube ich nett
doch
anscheinend ok wie viel wie viel füge ich da jetzt was hinzu dass jetzt
alles web interface ppega ingress allow all instances in network ip ranges specific port 22
so mal gucken ob das jetzt alleine schon reicht
da von da von bei das halt irgendwie damit dem default müsste eigentlich auch gehen
keine fehlermeldung mehr keine fehlermeldung mehr schauen ob es jetzt hier funktioniert
aha da sind wir
die anderen waren nicht für mein netzwerk die waren für was anderes das habe ich jetzt
am end wollen das habe ich gar nicht gesehen
stimmt das habe ich gar nicht gesehen ja ja du hast recht ok wir sind auf unserer vm
wait a minute keck wait ich habe kein public interface damit kann ich jetzt
ok das war eine blöde idee ganz ohne pappen da bräuchte ich jetzt
irgendeinen nattausgang und das mache ich jetzt nicht ich lege die ich
lege die vm lieber noch mal neu aber weg hier weg hier die lied wobei kann man das
nachträglich ändern dass er sich eine publik ip jetzt nimmt netwerking
boah da hört es oft da blicke ich nicht mehr durch feierball insatz das kann man auch bestimmt
nachträglich nachträglich ändern wie ändere ich von meiner ip edit
netwerking dazu muss ich sie bestimmt beenden dass es funktioniert
externe ip jetzt muss ich eine ip kriegen
wobei sshs immer noch nicht erlaubt ist also ihr würde da jetzt nicht drankommen per ssh
aber ich sollte jetzt ah jetzt funktioniert das ok nice also das würde das würde schon
funktionieren das ganze so zu tunneln und von da könnte ich jetzt ja wahrscheinlich auch auf
ja irgendwas anderes pingen aus diesem netz ich weiß bloß ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht was
haben wir denn hier was ist mein gut der wird sich der wird sich wahrscheinlich nicht pingen
lassen aber ich gehe mal davon aus dass ich von hier jetzt auch auf meinen kubernetes cluster
wenn ich einen hätte unsere drauf kommen würde ja gut wenn ich das komplette netzwerk wenn ich
aufs komplette netzwerk von mir zur lokal zugreifen will dann müsste ich in cloud vpn machen oder
irgendwelche ganz abgedrehten ssh tunnel geschichten aber das habe ich jetzt keinen
bock drauf ok mein vm ist tatsächlich relativ relativ easy an der stelle jetzt geh mal zum
anderen was ich noch nicht gemacht habe ich ausprobieren will also ob ich die vm brauche
bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher ich schweiß die auf jeden fall mal wieder weg weil kost geld
sql warum ist jetzt eigentlich hier unten das jetzt nicht mehr standardmäßig offen nach welchem
system funktioniert das jetzt ist es standardmäßig wieder offen und jetzt und jetzt wieder nicht
google logik ich will eine cloud sql machen eine postgres datenbank create instance jetzt war ich
blöden ab die vm gelöscht auch die sessi war bescheuert ich brauche die vm ja noch um zu
testen ob ich da dran kommen an die datenbank ok ich mache mal wieder eine vm sehr sehr high
IQ max create vm wir nennen die einfach wieder exakt gleich las vegas europ west london perfekt
frankfurt admin netzwerk trance options networking hostname jetzt brauchen wir alles
nicht network card auch nicht network interface default network das da ob der rest ist ok den
können wir so lassen das name is already news war doch eben schon weg admin 2 da muss ich nur
gucken dass ich hier admin 2 angebe sonst richtig pepega time ich frage mich warum es geht ok
cloud sql was wollen wir haben choose your database engine postgres ql choose postgres
jawoll soll ich euch das verraten oder gar nicht so sicher ob ich euch das verraten soll
ich verrate euch das nicht instance id ja ab db ich denke mir jetzt ich denke mir jetzt ein
passwort aus nur für den fall der fälle dass ich das mal für irgendwas irgendwas brauche gleich
ich will die datenbank so einstellen dass sie nicht von außen zugreifbar ist
production natürlich was sonst configuration details single development reicht
region single zone hier kann man seine datenbank auch automatisch replizieren
und so dass das lassen wir jetzt das kostet glaube ich nur unnötig geld
auch nach frankfurt
network connection public ip enable nein private ip private ip von diesem netzwerk
private was private services action was private services access connection
required your network requires a private service access connect was eine ok
ich mach mal ich weiß zwar nicht was ich von was von mir will aber ja
private service access vpc das ist das was wir vorhin angelegt haben can be
can be used across all managed service such as und weiter
ist es dass sie sich untereinander auflösen können oder wofür was was mein netzwerk ist doch
als sie sich auf eben
tja use automatic ja allocate immer automatic
create connection perfekt
drei stunden später ist meine vm mittlerweile wieder da
hey meine vm ist da okay nice
die macht bettgetime die connection
bettge setge übrigens wir müssen noch vom rack man die hintergründe einbinden
weil es kann eigentlich kann es nicht sein dass ich noch nicht die pepo dinger im hintergrund
hab also wir sollten die zumindest mal
sollten die zumindest mal runterladen und schon mal die passenden die passenden bilder
aussuchen guck mal was wir jetzt zum beispiel was wir was wir für die aktuelle tageszeit
angemessen das da eigentlich oder eigentlich der da max day ok download zip
ne ich hallo ich will alles runterladen google drive bedienung mensche
ja heute mal andere musik ist jetzt eigentlich fertig mit anlegen postgres ip is fertig private
service access connection has been successfully created authorized networks you have not authorized
any external networks will ich auch net enable private path glaube nicht dass ich das brauche
data protection flags ja gut create und safe jetzt erstelle meine datenbank da können wir uns mal
um die bilder es dauert noch ein bisschen ne das war schon ne ne ne ne ne creating so schnell
geht das natürlich nett kümmern wir uns doch gerade mal um die downloads enten wenn er irgendwie
wallpaper wallpaper wallpaper und zip ok ok so welchen brauchen wir jetzt
day pc moment wie setze ich wie setze ich mein hintergrund noch mal so
x pepo day pc da ist er
und jetzt müssen wir es auch so einrichten dass ich das nach urzeit automatisch fix aber da fällt
mir jetzt gar nichts ein also dass ich das nach urzeit automatisch einstellt
grondjob wird irgendwas im hintergrund laufen lassen was auch weil grondjob wird wenn du
sie vm ausgeschaltet wird einfach alles was alle fünf sekunden die urzeit checkt und gut ist die
vm hat über zwei die die db hat über zwei minuten gebraucht zu erstellen erstellt zu werden
ja brauche noch
erstellt
also gibt es hier gar keine bildforschung pass mal auf ich kann jetzt im terminal die
bilde anzeigen lassen oh fuck alle mein terminal ist mega ausgelastet wenn ich die bilde anzeigen
lasse ja was nehmen wir denn für was
mein aktuell gibt es nur den mit dem pc
hältst du dich an ordner strukturen ja wenn es sinn macht es ist halt oftmals total übertrieben
wenn ihr dir von irgend so einem java script scaffolding standardprojekt was anguckst dann
ist das sind es ja immer 150 dateien drinnen das erstelle ich am liebsten selbst aber ich
habe da so eine so eine also für die meisten sachen so eine eigene vorstellung wie es aussehen
soll aber dann mache ich es immer gleich ich denke mal das deckt sich zum größten teil auch
mit dem was so vorgeschlagen wird muss es nicht übertreiben ja wir haben gerade gewartet bis die
datenbank erstellt ist die islam im erstellen ja aber guck mal wir haben wir haben ihn schon
hier im hintergrund wir müssen gerade gucken was wir wie wo nehmen ich glaube ich meine
theoretisch dort wo wir mehrere bilder haben muss es ja auch nicht immer das gleiche bild sein es
könnte mal der sein es könnte mal der sein es könnte mal der sein es könnte mal der sein
wenn er wenn er frühstück am schlafen könnte es mal der sein bei der sein
also wir bräuchten dann quasi so eine group an ordnern quasi für für morning und so was und
day wobei wir können das war einfach greppen also wir können jetzt irgendwie so in go aber
ebis was hier krepp nach neid
das Hasta kratzen nach neid
ja und davon konnten wir jetzt random eins auswählen und anzeigen lassen
wie geht denn das? hier bash pick random from line
das habe ich mir noch nie gedacht select random lines from a file
keine ahnung wie man das gescheit macht schuff? was? was zum teufel? schuff?
ok es gibt es gibt für alles irgendein irgendein shell tool
moment was zum schuff? tatsächlich n1?
Leute null ok was es nicht alles gibt jetzt wählt jetzt random ein bild aus passend passend
zum zur uhrzeit jetzt bräuchte man eigentlich nur noch irgendwas was guckt von so viel uhr
gleich neid von so viel uhr gleich gleich das und das sind dann für so ein dreizeiler bash
das zu gucken was macht eigentlich unsere cloud instance daten? jetzt seriously google
was macht der denn da?
der created seit sieben minuten unsere datenbank was ist denn los mit dem?
da muss bestimmt irgendwie in den inner aus dem container für google jetzt drei
sachen eintippen und datenbank professionieren
naja das muss man nicht verstehen na gut lass uns mal kurz gucken noch mal
ich muss erstmal auf Gentoo kompilieren
lass uns doch mal irgendwie so ein 5 hat drei zeilen hier wallpaper.sh
hier das machen wir repos, scripts, repos helper, ne moment repos, scripts ja den können wir löschen
den braucht kein mensch mehr wallpaper.sh bin bash
lass chat gpt das wollen wir das mal ausprobieren? oh die datenbank ist created
ok ihr dürft mir nicht zugucken beim einloggen aber wir fragen chat gpt log in
ich weiß man chat gpt passt man mittlerweile aus wenn ihr so oft eingegeben
so alles klar ihr seid wieder am start ok schreibe mir ein bash script das je nach
tageszeit den desktop hintergrund ändert da fehlt ein bisschen zu wenig context
ok bestimme die aktuelle tageszeit überprüfe die tageszeit und ändere das hintergrundbild
entsprechend ja gar nicht schlecht so kann man das machen halt für gnome aber ok
ja das ist das ist gar nicht schlecht das kann man machen dass das das kann so funktionieren
ja das funktioniert so jetzt müssen wir noch jetzt müssen wir noch was anderes hinschreiben
und zwar mal gucken wir mal das kann desktop hintergrund ändert
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ah hi iq chat gpt am start
das habe ich auch letztens gesehen Serious Max das habe ich mal ausprobiert das habe
ich mir nicht gefallen das hat Mist Mist gefunden das ist schon mal viel besser schon mal viel
viel viel viel besser so ja das passt wie können wir chat gpt jetzt dazu kriegen wirklich das
genau zu machen wie wir wollen folgende bilder als input verwenden
moment
folgende bilder stehen zur auswahl gucken ob sie damit schon was anfangen kann wahrscheinlich
fahrt zum burger und getränke fahrt zum batman
aber der ist schon mal der ist schon mal schlau
und passt passt die sachen passt die sachen an wer für das letzte
so ich glaube wir müssen wir müssen wir müssen eine ordentliche liste machen und zwar so
ich muss besser erklären was ich was ich haben will ich will ja ich will ja dass
er random auswählt passend zur urzeit ich weiß aber nicht ob er die urzeit oder die den hier mit
sunrise und sunset kennt ich glaube jetzt wird wirklich einfacher als uns zu überlegen wie
über das chat gpt umschreiben lassen selbst zu machen wähle je nach urzeit
sag ihm doch dass der das der teile
verwende folgende
teile als hintergrund nein ah shit
er werden der folgende teile als hintergrund der dateiname enthält die tageszeit oder den
irgendwie sowas nicht tageszeit er enthält ja
schon besser schon besser schon besser wobei ich das halt auch mit einem ls machen würde kann ja
sein dass es gut ich glaube jetzt ist tatsächlich an der stelle einfacher weil was ich machen will
ist dass er sich random eins raussucht dann aber mal gucken mal gucken ob der ob er das jetzt ja
ist ja gut chat gpt komm gibby aber das erste das erste beispiel von chat gpt finde ich schon
also das erste beispiel ist tatsächlich ganz gut ja also das hier das hier ist ganz gut
ok wir probieren wir probieren wir probieren auch mal was aus wir probieren auch was aus
in einem ordner liegen dateien mit dateiname passend zur tageszeit wie zum beispiel
wähle je nach urzeit random ein passendes als hintergrund ich weiß ja nicht mal wie
schreiben soll richtig was in pyson monkeys wie kommt er jetzt auf einmal auf pyson
aber das soll mir auch recht sein
hast du geschehen es war die ganze zeit in basch
nee das ergibt weiß was scheiß drauf scheiß drauf wir machen das für man das wirklich schnell
selbst also wir nehmen wir nehmen aber tatsächlich das was chat gpt vorgeschlagen hat weil das ist
gar nicht so gar nicht so blöde ja das ist eigentlich ganz ganz gut und jetzt machen wir so
also sprich vormittags vielleicht wir können sogar wir können sogar die die die wer braucht
comments kackel ist so wobei wir auch ein bisschen bisschen mehr eigentlich bräuchten jetzt also
machen wir so wir nehmen jetzt random eins von ls la von hier so greb neid nur hier nicht greb
neid sondern knapp greb was ist es morning reck wie hast du die dinger reck man wir
an morning wie heißen die wie heißen die für morgens
morning oder morning nice day for fishing rap morning
morning okay da haben wir eins image
so da mache ich image und gucke ob das jetzt funktioniert was ich mir hier vorher nicht
für image so dann kommt das hier hin das kann man das kann man deutlich deutlich besser besser
machen anstatt es zu copy pasten so morning an der stelle brauche night und hier ist ja wie
heißt da fehlt noch sunset und sunrise und sowas day heißt das andere day okay gucken wir mal ob
das an sich funktioniert wallpaper.sh
chmod plus x wallpaper.sh
was ist was ist verkehrt ah ich bin ja auch blöd guck mal keck ich hab ja da die ganzen
muss es la weg machen
so was das not exist weil weil der fad fehlt okay ja das kann man das kann man mit
wahrscheinlich besser machen an der stelle feind nicht lsla sondern macht ein feind davor
dann hat man nämlich den ganzen fad auch noch mal gucken ob das jetzt prinzipiell funktioniert
schön ist es nett haha es funktioniert guck mal
eins ganz nice
aber das ist das ist noch sehr rudimentär alles also das würde ich tatsächlich noch
mal ein bisschen ein bisschen verbessern weil es gibt ja explizit bilder die sind für
die sind für fürs essen und es gibt explizit bilder die sind sunrise sunset und sowas
also das ist doch nicht wirklich gut außerdem ist das so wie wir das hier machen richtig richtig
abartig es wäre deutlich sinniger man macht hier ups man geht hier zum beispiel mal nach
ja das kann man ausprobieren das ist eine gute idee hier wallpaper
was wollte ich jetzt machen ihr feind genau das ist sinnvoller wir machen jetzt hier feind
also das ist bescheuert feind home downloads home max downloads wallpaper wallpaper ja
wenn man nämlich das dann hat man nämlich den ganzen fad mit drinne das ist deutlich
schon mal schon mal viel besser als diesen anderen müll den ich hier mache also hier
ein feind draus dann können wir uns nämlich kann man sich nämlich auch gleich diesen
ganzen krempel hier sparen und außerdem wäre es besser war nachdem ich das e doppelt mache
das kommt unten hin image hier image image gleich so und jetzt weisen wir hier drinne
zu und das geht wahrscheinlich in basch auch noch irgendwie schöner
wallpaper morning also moment morning day night
funktioniert immer noch
und das ist ein bisschen schöner ist jetzt müssen wir noch jetzt müssen
wir sunrise sunset machen man könnte sogar richtig dynamisch rauskriegen anhand wann
täglich sunset sunrise und so was ist wie sind die bilder noch aufgebaut also wir haben im
endeffekt wir haben morning sunset day moment das müssen wir anders machen sort ja also wir
haben day morning night night haben wir ganz viel das was wir am selbsten sehen wahrscheinlich
also wir haben day morning
ach nur wegen der no moon variant ok ich will die mit mit moon haben dann haben wir also wir haben
sunrise sunset
ne gibt kein bug gibt kein bug weil das habe ich schon berücksichtigt ich greppe nach
anders gore morning anders gore und das gibt es in der kombination nicht keck das also wir haben
lassen wir kurz gucken sunset sunrise so night haben wir morning day haben wir auch schon so
dann dann fragen wir noch chat gp thema was jeder meinung ist also
früher mal ergänze folgendes haben wir irgendwas vergessen reg man oder viel ist
es ist sunset und sunrise als einzige was mir was mir fehlt ich habe ich habe day morning night habe
ich jetzt ja schon also im prinzip glaub nicht ergänze folgendes kript um sunset und sunrise
ich habe keine ahnung ob es das checkt was ich von ihm will wahrscheinlich nicht
ok das ist schon mal clever das ist schon mal clever dass man sunset rauskriegt das ist schon
mal nicht blöd das ist schon mal nicht blöd dass man die wetter api abfragt wann es sunrise gibt
aber ich würde tatsächlich dazu übergehen dass das zu hardcoden ich glaube auch dass es ein bug
hat ich glaube auch das hat einen bug oder weil das zeigt nachts an
ich das ist mir zu 6 hat aber würde das jetzt nicht nachts anzeigen weil es zwischen sunset
und sunrise ist und da hat sunrise auch gar nicht drinnen aber der guck mal der hat sunrise auch
gar nicht gar nicht drinnen das ist das ist das funktioniert so nicht in best ist das ende
wirklich viel ja ne der hat der hat kein der hat kein sunrise drin hat nur hier sunset night day
morning morning machen wir mal von hand also wenn eins ist im prinzip ganz einfach else if also wenn
es nach 6 und vor 9 ist machen wir jetzt einfach mal ja das ist sunrise oder nach 5 wobei das
eigentlich egal ist wenn es nach 6 und vor 9 ist dann ist das ding so das nächste wenn es nach 9
ist und vor 12 dann ist es morning ist man damit für den sup die eisfrieg
sunrise fehlt
guck mal mal
aber es zeigt keine sunrise bilder an das was fehlt ja ok das ist schon besser das ist schon
besser das ist eigentlich ganz gut jetzt ja ok ich hätte ich würde ich hätte die
zeit ein bisschen anders verteilt ja also es ist aber schon ziemlich ähnlich zu dem was ich
jetzt hier gerade mache also wenn wenn zeit größer als sechs kleiner als neun dann ist
sunrise so das stings so dann brauchen wir noch ein letztes brauchen wir noch ein letztes
sunset sunset ist von 18 uhr bis 21 uhr
wir machen kommen ich mache bis 20 uhr von von 17 aber 17 dann sieht man die dinger nämlich
auch mal ansonsten sieht man sie ja gar nicht und das muss schon 21 21 uhr sein weil sonst
ja müsste müsste eigentlich jetzt ganz gut funktionieren ok
das funktioniert immer noch
ok da probieren wir mal aus was jetzt eigentlich bei unserer cloud datenbank machen wir mal
unsere cloud datenbank mittlerweile da er hat er hat es geschafft zu erstellen ok dann schauen
wir mal ob wir uns von der vm sind wir sind jetzt ein wenig ab abgeschwiffen vom eigentlichen
thema google clouds ok wir verbinden uns auf die form was haben die was hat die cloud für
eine ip hier die die cloud datenbank pingen ok pingen kann ich die datenbank schon mal nicht
wahrscheinlich ist es aber absicht dass man die nicht pingen kann aber hinkommen sollte ich da
oder aber n map report wird für port scan jetzt einfach mal was ist ein postgres für
postgres port telnet auf was ist was hatten das postgres postgres default port 5 4 3 2 telnet
telnet
geht nice verbindung zur datenbank funst ab install pgs oder wie heißt das ding
install pgs kiel debian ich will ja kein postgres installieren sondern nur das cli
postgres common oder sowas muss ich da wahrscheinlich installieren
abzeits postgres heißt es kleint tatsächlich ab install
bsql so das weiß ich jetzt aus dem kopf nicht wir können auch nicht chat gpt fragen
bsql connect weil ich habe das fenster schon wieder zugemacht die parameter ist minus h für
host ne boah keine ahnung weiß ich doch nicht auswendig
minus klein h for root ok password for root password fail for root habe ich den user
vorhin irgendwie anders anders genannt wie habe ich in den wie habe ich in den user
vorhin genannt cloud instances boah ne keine ahnung kann man das hat man irgendwie noch die
chance das zu sehen users username postgres
ne
select ich habe keine ahnung
oder wie lists wie konnte man sich die vorhandenen databases anzeigen lassen
list databases ich habe sql bin ich wirklich absoluter noob show show databases
ne
nop listing backslash l what the fuck backslash l welcher kobold programmierer hat sich das
denn damals ausgedacht
es ist schlimm man ist das was postgres spezifisches keine ahnung
slash dt list table wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich ist es auch noch standard
das ist wir das kommt aus grauer zeit vorzeit diese sachen wo die alle erfunden wurden da hat
sich irgendein typ gedacht ich habe keinen bock über den terminal in meinem 80 zeichen breiten
text editor da einzugeben was langes ich will backslash machen ok also wir haben auch eine
cloud datenbank schon mal ganz nice jetzt müssen wir uns nur noch überlegen wie wir das ganze in
terraform kriegen und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob ich da heute noch bock drauf habe die
datenbank in terraform anzulegen weil später müssen wir ja die credentials von der datenbank
irgendwie in ein environment in eine environment variable vom container bzw für die für das
deployment in unserem cluster kriegen damit der dann auf die datenbank connecten kann
es könnte allerdings auch sein terraform import das ist eine wirklich gute idee das
mache ich jetzt auch es können natürlich auch sein dass man google cloud das secret irgendwie
exportieren lassen kann also dass man dieses secret irgendwie exportieren lassen kann hier
in den in den in den password manager oder sowas weiß nicht vielleicht geht vielleicht geht das
ja auch ok oder da drüber ja ok na was muss ich mir mal muss ich mir mal gedanken zumachen
so ja aber wie kriegst du es da rein das soll ja automatisch passieren wir machen
terraform import und jetzt hört es bei mir auf keine ahnung import google cloud zeusch
terraform import ok und jetzt wahrscheinlich ja gut da muss man muss man gucken wie das
heißt cloud sql database instance hallo was wo sind wir hier google sql database
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was es in dem fall macht
ich probiere jetzt mal aus ok ich weiß überhaupt nicht wie es funktioniert
ok und dann muss man angeben wie das ding heißt ach so verstehe also ich habe ein
projekt stream slash abdeb ich habe bis chat gpt schon wieder ausgeloggt
ja und die fault warum warum genau punkt die fault man weiß es nicht
ich habe keine ahnung wie es funktioniert
so ich soll quasi irgendwie so ein platzhalter oder so einfügen
ja
was?
Name? Muss ich das jetzt AppDB nennen, dass das funktioniert?
Okay, ich bin zu dumm dafür, keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Achso.
Ey, kein Plan, man.
Echt, echt kein Plan, wie das funktionieren soll.
Missing Parameter, Instance.
Moment, ich dachte, das macht er für mich.
Wait a minute.
Das, ach, das importiert nur in den State.
Ich dachte, das kann, das kann auch daraus.
Achso, ich muss die anlegen, wie Terraform sie anlegen würde und dann darf ich eine
bestehende schon importieren.
Ich dachte, kann man nicht aus schon bestehenden Cloud-Ressourcen Terraform-Files erzeugen
um danach sie wieder aufzubauen?
Also, wahrgenommen, ich habe schon was über Google Cloud aufgebaut, dass ich daraus ein
Terraform-File erzeuge.
Das wäre doch, das wäre doch Pfeil für den Export, Export hier Google Cloud Ressourcen
into Terraform-Format, nice, okay.
Prepare Cloud Shell, install config, aha.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal noch schnell aus.
Die haben den hässlichsten Progress-Balken aller Zeiten.
Okay, Google, weil ihr es seid, ich mache das alles und jetzt export the entire, nein,
nein, nein, nein, ich will nicht die Entire-Project, ich will nur, ich will nur meine Datenbank,
okay, komm, scheiße, mal was mal, bulk-export, ja, okay, was, okay, yes, yes, yes, yes, ich
lasse die da erstmal alles installieren, was auch immer, das halbe Internet wird runtergeladen
gerade.
Nicht, dass da jetzt Passwörter und so drinstehen, das wäre ziemlich kacke.
Chat, ich muss euch glaube ich erstmal ausblenden, wenn ich die Datei jetzt aufmache.
Ich weiß nicht, was da drinsteht, alles im Klartext.
Leaked.
Ah hier, resource-type.
Da kann man dann auch Cloud SQL reinschreiben.
Macht der jetzt noch was?
Der ist wahrscheinlich einfach langsam as fuck, ja, der exportiert gerade mein ganzes
Projekt, das ist ja plötzlich Blödsinn.
Wir sagen jetzt einfach resource-types gleich und wer weiß ich, welche resource-types es
gibt?
Compute-instance.
Was?
Ah, da muss man jetzt Project angeben.
Stream.
Was ist das?
Completed.
Admin 2, ja, okay, alles klar.
Scopes.
Ah, hier ist die ganzen, ganzen Settings von der VM.
CLI tool to generate Terraform files from existing infrastructure.
Terraformer.
Okay.
Jetzt wird's Sixhead, Google Cloud.
Das macht doch, das benutzt es, dieses Tool benutzt es doch unter der Haube bestimmt
auch.
Wie heißt denn die richtige, der richtige resource-type?
ECP resource-type, woher weiß ich denn, was es da welche gibt?
Supported resource-types, SQL, ne, ich weiß gar nicht, woher ich weiß, welche.
List resource-type, SQL database, genau.
Oh, was?
Invalid argument found that matches asset, was, for a list of supported content types.
Okay.
Nur normalen Export.
Kein Bulk-Export, ich will ja auch keinen Bulk exportieren.
Ah ne, Moment, Export.
Alter, das wird zu dumm, keine Ahnung, ich leg's lieber von Hand nochmal an.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktionieren soll.
Wie funktioniert das hier?
Ne, das mach ich jetzt nicht, ich leg das nochmal von Hand an, um gut ist.
So, aber was ich jetzt machen werde ist, weil wir haben ja alles erstmal ausprobiert, was
wir heute ausprobieren wollten.
Was ich jetzt machen werde ist das Projekt löschen, das ist nämlich alles weg.
Docker-Images löschen, yes, nope, da will ich hin, ach Quatsch, wo ist das nochmal?
Managed Resources, ja, bam, delete, delete, bam, nice, alles klar Leute, das reicht mir
für heute.
Ich hab jetzt schon genug gebastelt, ich krieg jetzt schon langsam aber sicher wieder
Hunger.
Nächsten Stream, erinnern wir uns glaube ich mal dem Kubernetes-Cluster da drauf dann.
Ich muss doch gucken, wie man das ganze professionlicher raid, wen soll ich raiden, okay, wir gucken
mal was.
Twitch, Programming, wer ist denn da am Start, jetzt geht auf Deutsch, iFreesy, ist da Frasher
gewesen in letzter Zeit auf Twitch, irgendwelche Weep-Dinger, Programming, wer ist denn hier
am Start, Programming Lectures, beliebte Clips, alle Videos, nope, was, vor 6 Jahren, wait
a minute, aber es sind da keine Leute gerade online, oder ist da niemand live gerade in
dieser Kategorie, kann das sein, wait, Moment, ach das ist der, es heißt ja auch Software
im Game, das heißt ja nicht mal Programming, zwei Tetris Streams oder 2K, 5Heads, 5Heads
Zeug, gecommodet am Start, Kanäle auf Deutsch, C-Sharp, Stelzer, wie heißt das andere, Science,
da ist ja gar keiner am Start, da ist ja nur wirklich mal gar niemand da, die Kategorie
benutzt ja wirklich niemand, wie es aussieht, keine Ahnung, wen ich hoste, ich kenne alle
nicht, ich geh jetzt was fressen Leute, bis denn, see you.